Ich frage mich ja, ob irgendjemand schon mal herausgefunden hat, was die da eigentlich gerade abzählen. Weiß das einer von euch Daten, Daten, das sind nämlich Kraftwerk und dieser Song ist jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat der Opener zum Chaos Radio Blue Moon hier auf Ritz. Das heißt, es ist wieder letztes Mittwoch im Monat. Ihr seid beim Chaos Radio und bei mir sind Frank Rosengard.
Hallo, hallo und Erdgeist.
Guten Abend.
Und es geht heute um den Datenbrief. So fragt euch vielleicht als erstes, was ist denn das? Und es ist genau das, womit wir anfangen wollen. Bevor wir das aber klären, gibt es noch mal Sachen zu sagen. Es gibt eine Mitmachseite, ein sogenanntes Wiki, da könnt ihr Sachen reinschreiben oder Fragen stellen, die euch interessieren. Das könnt ihr auch im Chat tun. Aber die Links gibt es, wie gesagt, das gibt es alles im Wiki. Und die Links dort gibt es unter chaosradio.de. Da könnt ihr einfach klicken, da findet ihr alles, was ihr noch braucht. Mitmachen ist erwünscht. Aber natürlich und vor allem auch unter dieser Nummer. Genau. Wenn ihr also Fragen habt, also wenn hier irgendwas geredet wird, wo ihr denkt so, hä, Moment, stopp, ich bin nicht mitgekommen, dann ruft an. Wir erklären es. Wenn ihr eine Frage habt zum Datenbrief, ruft an, stellt die. Wenn ihr Kritik habt am Datenbrief, ruft an, dann können wir drüber reden. Und überhaupt ist das hier ganz wichtig.
Eure Meinung jetzt anrufen.
0331 70 97 110.
Wie gesagt, erst kennen wir aber mal, was dieser komische Datenbrief überhaupt ist. Die Herren vom Chaos Computer Club, was ist denn ein Datenbrief?
Die Idee vom Datenbrief ist, dass jeder Bürger oder jede Firma, jede Behörde, die irgendwas über mich gespeichert hat, muss mich einmal im Jahr darüber informieren, was sie von mir für Daten gespeichert hat. Es ist also eine Art Kontuauszug für meine Daten. Sei es also, wie ich monatlich oder alle zwei Monate oder sowas einen Kontuauszug von meiner Bank mit meinen Umsätzen und sowas alles bekomme, bekomme ich dann von den Firmen und Behörden, die Daten über mich gespeichert haben. Jedes Jahr eine Information, sehr geehrter Herr Rosenhardt, folgende Daten haben wir über sie gespeichert. Das ist die Idee dabei. Und der Gedanke dahinter ist, dass einerseits natürlich die Bürger wirklich eine Idee davon bekommen sollen, welche Daten über sie in Umlauf sind. Und andererseits für die Firmen, aber ein kleines Stückchen unattraktiver gemacht werden soll, Daten zu speichern oder zumindest große Datenmengen zu speichern. Das heißt also, die Idee ist, dass Firmen sich Gedanken machen sollen, weil so ein Briefversand kostet ja auch ein bisschen Geld und kostet ein bisschen Aufwand. Ob es wirklich nötig ist, die Daten ganz lange zu speichern oder ob man die nicht einfach nach einem Jahr oder noch früher wieder löschen kann, wenn man sie nicht mehr braucht.
Oh, wait, okay, das ist schon die erste Nachfrage. Wir reden jetzt tatsächlich von einem Brief. Wir reden von einem Totholzmedium Papier?
Nicht unbedingt, nein. Also die Idee ist, dass wenn ich eine E-Mail-Adresse habe, dann könnte ich sowas auch per E-Mail verschicken. Man könnte sowas auch online machen. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt irgendwo bei einem Forum oder irgendwo bei einem Online-Shop, wenn ich da einen Online-Account habe und ich melde mich da an, dass ich dann einfach die Daten einsehen kann, die auch wirklich über mich vorhanden sind.
Das ist ganz einfach die Art und Weise, auf der man normalerweise den Kunden kontaktiert oder im Fall einer Behörde, also den Bürger kontaktiert, über genau dasselbe Medium, sei es ein Brief, sei es eine E-Mail, die man auch gespeichert hat. Über dieses Medium soll auch der Brief verschickt werden. Also man soll nicht als Einladung missverstanden werden, jetzt auch noch zusätzliche Informationen, wie die Adresse erst sich kommen zu lassen. Wenn man mit dem Kunden nur Kontakt per E-Mail hatte, dann reicht es, wenn man wirklich sich genötigt zieht, diese Daten zu behalten.
Ich möchte ja aber lieber nicht, dass sozusagen manche Firmen, die nicht nur über E-Mail Kontakt hatte, meine Daten per E-Mail durchs Netz schicken. Weil E-Mail unverschlüsselt, kann jeder mitlesen und so, da meine Datensammlung, ne.
Die Idee ist auch sowieso, dass nicht deine Daten verschickt werden, sondern ein Hinweis darauf, dass Daten gespeichert werden, welcher Art diese Daten sind, aber natürlich nicht der Inhalt. Und ganz wichtig, wie du diese Daten dann in Erfahrung bringen kannst, wenn du es wirklich wissen möchtest oder wie du die Möglichkeit hast, diese Daten wieder zu entfernen, wenn du möchtest, dass die Firma diese Daten...
Ja, aber das kann ich doch jetzt auch schon machen.
Dazu musst du erst einmal wissen, dass diese Daten dort vorliegen. Und das ist ja meistens das Problem, dass so Daten, die dann über komische Klauseln bei dritten Firmen landen, dann an den unglaublichsten Stellen auftauchen, wo du normalerweise keine Ahnung hast, dass die Daten jetzt an Partnerfirmen weitergegeben worden sind. Und von denen möchtest du eigentlich informiert werden. Und möchtest ihnen dann mal aufs Dach steigen und sagen, ja, wo habt ihr denn die her? Und erlöscht die mal Umgänge sofort. Und diese Chance hast du nicht, wenn du nicht darüber informiert wirst, dass die Daten dann auch noch bei den Partnerfirmen herumliegen.
Habt ihr da mal irgendwie so Schätzungen angestellt, über den Daumen gepeilt, wie viel Datenbriefe ein normaler du und ich Nutzer bekommen würde?
Ich glaube, das ist nicht so der Mehraufwand für eine Firma, die ja hier empfunden wird. Nee, nee, darum geht es nicht.
Sondern ich als Typ, der jetzt die Daten von mir haben.
Genau, wie viel kriege ich dann pro Jahr? Ich würde mal sagen schon 100. Wobei, aber dazu muss ich auch sagen, von den 100 sind mindestens 80, die mir den in elektronischer Form zustellen könnten.
Aber trotzdem sozusagen, ich habe jetzt irgendwie 100 Datenbriefe. Und wenn ich mir angucke, wie viele Leute bereit will ich die allgemeinen Geschäftsbedingungen von sozialen Netzwerken, die sie benutzen, durchlesen, was meint ihr denn, wie viele Leute tatsächlich diese 100 Datenbriefe lesen?
Naja, du musst ja nicht durchlesen, aber du bekommst ihn immerhin. Und es soll natürlich auch, das haben wir auch vorgesehen, es gibt eine sogenannte Opt-out-Möglichkeit. Das heißt, ich kann also ein Kreuzchen machen, sagen, nein, ich möchte den Datenbrief nicht, weil es mir vielleicht zu peinlich ist, wenn mir irgendwie der erwachsene Spielzeug Sexversender, wie auch immer, mir die Daten ins Haus schickt. Da kann ich auch danke darauf verzichten. Das ist mir jetzt nicht so wichtig, die Daten zu bekommen. Das sind so Optionen, die wir auf jeden Fall vorsehen. Aber die Grundidee ist, da müssen wir noch mal ganz kurz zurück, also eigentlich ist die ursprüngliche Idee, dass diese Daten wirklich vollständig geschickt werden. Das war unsere Grundidee dabei. Und dass ich auch wirklich genau sehen kann, welche Daten sind es, und dass ich auch sehen kann, ob sie richtig sind. Das ist ja ein ganz riesengroßes Problem, gerade bei so Firmen wie bei der Schufa zum Beispiel, die also ein sehr umfassendes Profil haben über mich unter Umständen und wo auch eine ganze Menge Dinge von abhängen. Zum Beispiel, ob ich einen Handyvertrag bekomme, ob ich jetzt irgendwie wie hoch mein Dispo mir zugestanden wird bei der Bank, ob ich möglicherweise eine Wohnung bekomme oder nicht. Das sind alles so Sachen, die dann bei der Schufa angefragt werden. Und da ist es für mich natürlich schon mal ganz spannend zu wissen, welche Daten denn tatsächlich über mich da sind.
Aber gerade bei der Schufa kann ich das doch sogar umsonst nachfragen.
Jetzt neuerdings, ja. Ich denke mal, die Schufa ist wahrscheinlich an der Stelle dadurch, dass jetzt diese Auskunftspflicht besteht. Andererseits muss ich dazu auch wirklich erstmal die Idee haben. Also ich muss auch schon erstmal wissen, was die Schufa ist damit. Also es muss mir irgendwie bewusst sein, so dadurch. Und ich denke, dass viele Bürger einfach auch gar nicht so eine Idee haben, was die dann wirklich haben, also in welchem Umfang diese Daten haben. Das heißt also, da gibt es vielleicht eine Auskunft oder sowas, aber so eine Auskunft des, was ich im Kleingedruckten dann unterschreibe, wenn ich irgendwo einen Telefonvertrag abschließe oder so. Da sagt mir nichts aus, was die denn tatsächlich über mich haben oder was diese Schufa eigentlich ist. Was wir natürlich auch in diesem Datenbrief gern drin haben wollen, sind nicht nur die Informationen, wie sie jetzt da angelegt sind mit Name, Anschrift und vielleicht noch Geburtsdatum, sondern wir wollen auch gerne Datenbewegungen haben. Das heißt also, wenn Daten von einer Stelle zur nächsten gegangen sind, wenn Daten irgendwo angefragt worden sind, wenn Daten irgendwo weitergegeben worden sind, dann soll es da auch aufgeführt werden, dass ihr einfach eine Möglichkeit habt nachzuvollziehen. Einerseits, wo kommen die Daten her und wo gehen Daten hin?
Das ist aber auch, aber die Daten sollen nicht drinstehen. Das heißt, ich erfahre, welche Daten über mich abgespeichert wurden und was damit gemacht wurde, ohne genau zu wissen, was da drinsteht. Das könnte ich im Zweifel, wenn ich es will, noch erfragen.
Das ist noch ein Detailproblem. Das war jetzt auch der Einwand von den Leuten, also auch gerade von der Industrie gesagt haben, der wollen wir nicht, auf gar keinen Fall. Dann haben die gesagt, ja, und überlegt euch auch mal, werden diese Daten durch die Gegend geschickt werden und das ist ja auch ein Datenschutz und das geht ja nicht und ihr könnt ja auch in falsche Hände kommen. Bei E-Mails denke ich, ist die Chance relativ gering, dass die in falsche Hände kommen. Briefkasten, ja gut, aber gerade bei E-Mails ist es doch sozusagen super einfach, dass die in falsche Hände kommen, weil die ja im Sinne von falsch zugestellt werden. Also dass sie jemand anders zugestellt werden. Das ist das Argument bei Briefen, dass ein Brief vielleicht mal falsch zugestellt wird. Man kann sagen, ja kann sein, aber wahrscheinlich in 99, 99% der Briefe werden die richtig zugestellt. Eigentlich ist das auch nicht ein wirkliches Argument, aber das wäre eine Sache, wo wir sagen könnten, okay, wenn in diesem Datenbrief sauber genug aufgeschlüsselt ist, welche Daten tatsächlich vorhanden sind, dann wäre das auch eine Sache, wo wir sagen könnten, okay, wir können auch damit leben, wenn diese Datenfelder beschrieben sind. Also da steht dann nicht nur, wir haben ihre Anschrift, sondern da steht, wir haben irgendwie Straße, Hausnummer, Postleitzahl, Scoringwert für ihr Wohngebiet oder so. Das sind ja alles so Daten, die dann reingehören. Und da ist es eigentlich jetzt so, da geht es ja wirklich in die einerseits juristische oder technische Feinarbeit auch diese Sachen genau so zu beschreiben, so zu formulieren, dass sich die Firmen dann nicht da wieder rausreden können und sagen, naja, wir haben das ja irgendwie so ein bisschen nett zusammengefasst und mit irgendwelchen kryptischen Datenbankfeldern kann ja der Kunde sowieso nichts anfangen. Deswegen haben wir das einfach mal als Anschrift zusammengefasst oder als Kundendaten zusammengefasst.
Also ich finde es hört sich irgendwie so nach einem von diesen Dingern an, im ersten Moment eine gute Idee, aber dann kommen doch viele Fragen. Die könnt ihr heute stellen, wenn ihr das wollt, weil dazu sind die Leute auch hier.
Eure Meinung jetzt anrufen.
0331 70 97 110.
Und der erste, der diese Gelegenheit wahrgenommen hat, ist der Frank.
Hallo Frank.
Ja hallo.
Du hast eine Frage.
Zum Datenbrief.
Ja genau. Wer überwacht denn, welche Daten an mich überhaupt übersandt werden? Es kann ja eine Firma sonst noch was für Daten von mir haben und schickt nur die Hälfte an mich raus. Wer überprüft das, ob sie auch wirklich alles raus schicken?
Also die Aufgabe sowas überprüfen ist auch wie bisher schon die Aufgabe der Datenschutzbeauftragten der Länder oder des Bundes, die jeweils zuständig sind. Und auf die kommen dann natürlich neue Aufgaben hinzu. Einerseits sowas überprüfen, ob die Daten auch wirklich vollzählig sind. Und es müssen natürlich auch Abschreckungsmaßnahmen da sein, sprich Bußgelder, wenn diese Firmen das nicht vollständig machen. Also klar kann es natürlich immer sein, dass irgendwelche Daten irgendwo gespeichert sind und vielleicht für irgendwelche Tests mal irgendwelche besondere Daten erzeugt worden sind, das aber nicht der zentralen EDV oder der Rechtsabteilung oder wie auch immer gemeldet worden ist. Und die Daten gibt es trotzdem. Das wird natürlich auch immer passieren, aber das ist Sache der Datenschutzbeauftragten. Wenn die sowas bei einer Kontrolle feststellen, dann können ja auch entsprechenden Bußgeld verhängen. Wie bisher auch. Auch wenn jetzt bei der Datenverarbeitung schlampen und irgendwelche Sicherheitsmaßnahmen nicht einhalten oder unbefugt irgendwelche Daten weitergeben an Dritte, dann können genauso Bußgelder auch verhängt werden. Das ist natürlich, also es ist ein neues Stück Arbeit dazu, kommt dazu für die Datenschutzkontrollen. Aber das wäre dann halt so. Ja, nein, also garantieren können wir das damit natürlich nicht, aber es ist mal ein Anfang und ich persönlich glaube auch, dass es für Firmen sogar einen positiven Effekt hätte. Das klingt vielleicht ein bisschen komisch, aber ich glaube, dass man Kunden einfach damit positiv beglücken kann oder dass es für Kunden einfach einen guten Eindruck macht, wenn sich die Firmen um Transparenz bemühen und sagen wirklich, wir haben einfach keine Geheimnisse, hier sind die Daten und bitte kontrollieren sie auch nochmal, ob sie richtig sind, weil wir wollen sie ja umfangreich und richtig betreuen, blablabla. Man kann das mit einem netten Kunden anschreiben machen, das muss ja nicht so ein grauer Behördenbrief oder sowas sein, sondern man kann sowas ja auch ein bisschen netter gestalten. Wenn ich jetzt weiß, ich muss sowieso einmal im Jahr irgendwie einen Mailing machen und die Kunden informieren, dann kann ich ja auch noch irgendwie was Nettes dazuschreiben, ein Angebot Flyer oder so was dazu packen, dann lohnt sich das Ganze auch.
Aha, das ist aber hauptsächlich für die, bei den Firmen so, wo ich jetzt meine Daten so im Allgemeinen hinterlegt habe. Und das ist, weil ich, ich krieg ja andauernd auch Gewinnspiele und was ich überall gewonnen habe, wo haben die Leute denn meine Daten her?
Das wirst du dann mit dem Datenbrief erfahren.
Achso, und das erfahre ich dann mit dem Datenbrief.
Genau.
Das ist dann die Firma, wo ich meine Daten hinterlegt habe, wo super transparent war und dann meine Daten weitergegeben hat.
Sie wird das wahrscheinlich gemacht haben, weil du dem eingewilligt hast, dass sie das machen. Ich sag wahrscheinlich, natürlich so und dann solche, aber in der Regel hast du dem irgendwo eingewilligt, mal aus Versehen. Und wenn diese Daten erstmal in diesem Datenkreislauf sind, dann sind sie da einfach und die bekommst du da auch nicht wieder raus. Die Idee ist aber, dass mit diesem Datenbrief, der Datenhandel und dieser Datenkreislauf, dieses Daten am Leben halten, aktiv halten der Daten, dass das Daten auch ein Stückchen teurer gemacht wird, weil die Firmen natürlich auch informieren müssen, dass sie die Daten haben. Und dann wird es einfach auch zu so einem finanziellen Wirtschaftsfaktor sagen, okay, ich hab jetzt diese Daten, aber ich weiß, mich kostet es. Mich kostet es auf jeden Fall einmal im Jahr 55 Cent, diesen Brief rauszuschicken oder mit ein bisschen Papier und einem Drumherum sagen wir vielleicht ein Euro. Das heißt, diese Daten sind dann nicht mehr kostenlos. Das ist halt einfach nicht mehr eine CD voll mit 2 Millionen Datensätzen, sondern diese 2 Millionen Datensätze kosten dann halt einfach auch einen Jahr lang zu behalten, kosten sie dann einfach auch 2 Millionen Euro. Das ist die Idee dabei.
Na gut, wenn das jetzt so kontrolliert werden, wenn die Möglichkeiten überhaupt da sind vom Datenschutzbeauftragten, dass er überhaupt die Möglichkeit hat, das zu überprüfen bei den jeweiligen Firmen. Das ist ja ohne so ein Ding.
Wie überprüfen wir das?
Frank, die Frage ist ja sozusagen, du bist, also grundsätzlich findest du den Datenbrief eine gute Idee?
Ja.
Okay, meine Frage wäre jetzt die, würdest du sagen, der soll nicht realisiert werden, weil es möglicherweise nicht genug Kontrollinstanzen dafür gibt?
Na ja, sicher ist es gut, wenn er realisiert wird. Nur, es ist eben immer so die Sache, ja, wer macht das denn? Und die Datenschutzbeauftragten, die haben ja auch nur 24 Stunden am Tag Zeit, rein theoretisch ihre eigene Lebenszeit jetzt. Da müssten ja Unmengen von Datenschutzbeauftragten eingeschützt werden.
Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass der Datenschutzbeauftragte ein einzelner Mann ist, der sozusagen alle Datenschutzaufgaben in dem Bundesland macht. Das ist schon sozusagen eine Behörde.
Das ist schon klar, ja. Aber die Leute, die das jetzt schon machen, die sind wahrscheinlich jetzt schon überlastet.
Die sind überlastet auf jeden Fall.
Also, da müssten wir ja über zwei Jahren keine Arbeitslosen mehr haben auf jeden Fall.
Nein, es ist so, dass die Datenschutzbeauftragten jetzt schon entweder bei einem Verdacht eine Kontrolle durchführen können und das auch machen. Oder einfach routinemäßig sich mal Firmen anschauen. Und natürlich gerade so heikle Firmen, die im Adresshandelbereich sind oder die jetzt, weiß nicht, wie irgendwelche vielleicht Lebensversicherungen oder Krankenversicherungen, die unterliegen da natürlich schon auch einem etwas schärferen Blick. Und ja, wenn bei so was bei einer Kontrolle auffällt, also als Bürger, sobald einer mal einen Datenbrief schickt, hast du ja auch die Möglichkeit, so was nachzuvollziehen. Und kannst dann auch entsprechend die Behörden vielleicht darauf ansetzen.
Na gut, da bin ich ja mal gespannt, ob denn die 10 oder 20 Datenbriefe, die ich so kriegen werde in einem Jahr.
Na aber du kannst beim nächsten Mal, wenn du so ein Gewinnspiel wieder bekommst, dir einfach mal den Spaß machen, um zu sagen, den Spiel umzudrehen, den Brief hinzuschicken und zu sagen, bitte senden Sie mir mal sofort alle Daten, die Sie bei mir gespeichert haben, zu, weil das Recht hast du zurzeit schon. Und dann müssen die dann mal anfangen, die Karten offen auf den Tisch zu legen, wo du eingewilligt hast, deine Daten weiterzureichen. Mach denen doch ruhig auch mal ein bisschen Arbeit, weil deine Rechte, die du als mündiger Datenbürger hast, die musst du natürlich auch immer wahrnehmen, um nicht von denen über den Tisch gezogen zu werden.
Na dann, wenn du den ersten Datenbrief bekommen hast, rufst du mal an und erzählst, was da so drin stand. So, die Idee vom Datenbrief ist ja schon ein bisschen älter. Da wird gerade wieder drüber berichtet, weil da politisch drüber diskutiert wird, also von der fixen Idee dieses komischen Chaos Computer Clubs. Du hattest ein bisschen weitere Kreise gezogen. Was ist denn da gerade der Stand?
Also ich muss auch fairerweise sagen, dass wir auch nicht die Ersten sind, die mit der Idee aufgekommen sind.
Ach, das ist gar nicht eure Idee.
Habt ihr das quasi schwarz kopiert?
Vielleicht der Begriff ist unsere Idee. Nein, es gab schon länger mal eine Initiative vom Fürgut in Bielefeld, auch ein befreundeter Verein, ich glaube Stopp 1984 Organisation, die auch schon mal darüber nachgedacht hatten. Das ist allerdings ein paar Jahre her. Und damals war das vielleicht noch nicht so mehrheitsfähig durch den ganzen Datenskandale in den letzten Jahren und jetzt aktuell auch die ganze Facebook-Diskussion und Google-Straight-View und weiß nicht was, haben uns jetzt eigentlich nochmal dazu veranlasst zu sagen, ok, jetzt ist nochmal genau der richtige Zeitpunkt, das Thema nochmal richtig hoch aufzuhängen. Wir können es als Chaos Computer Club machen. Mittlerweile hören ein paar Leute auf uns und wir machen das jetzt mal und überlegen das mal und gehen auch eigentlich mit einer sehr weit aufgestellten Forderung rein und sagen, ok, wir wollen das jetzt, mach das jetzt bitte.
Eigentlich ist die Idee gar nicht so weit hergeholt. Du hast ja bisher ein Auskunftsrecht, aber du kannst es nicht wirklich wahrnehmen, wenn du nicht Bescheid sagst. Das ist eigentlich nur eine Regelungslücke, die wir da versuchen, dann mal durch politischen Druck zu schließen.
Ok, dass sie sozusagen politischen Druck mit einer Idee zusammenbringen, das sie überhaupt leisten können, das hat auch schon für ein bisschen Augenbrauen hochziehen gesorgt. Der Datenbrief ist, wie gesagt, schon länger in der Diskussion. Im März gab es ein paar Block-Einträge von Leuten, die das ganze Konzept nicht so cool finden. Unter anderem auch von jemandem, der sich Block-Fürst nennt und der meint zum Beispiel, ein paar ZZ-Zähler sind wohl vom PR-Virus befallen worden. Das im Regelfall zu Beratungsresistenz und mangelnder Bodenhaftung führt, weil er die Idee halt wirklich nicht so großartig findet. Aber das kann er uns am besten gleich selber sagen. Der ist jetzt am Telefon. Hallo und guten Abend.
Ja, hallo, schönen guten Abend. Also ich hab das jetzt glücklicherweise ein bisschen mitverfolgt von dem letzten Anrufer. Und ich möchte natürlich vorne weg mal sagen, dass der, also das Ziel, was der Datenbrief haben will, da sind wir uns letztlich irgendwie alle einig, dass da so möglichst wenig Daten insgesamt verhoben, weitergeleitet werden und wie auch immer. Nur womit ich halt, was ich halt einfach nicht verstehe, das wäre vielleicht die erste Frage hier in die Runde. Ich hab mal schnell geguckt. 2009 hat es auch eine Pressemitteilung vom CCC gegeben, in dem sie unter anderem die Abschaffung des Listenprivilegs gefordert haben. Und was ich eben von dem Frager und der Antwort herausgehört hab, ist ja insbesondere diese Datenhandelei, die in großen Daten setzen. Das ist so das große Problem.
Ich müsste an dieser Stelle kurz, was ist das Listenprivileg?
Das Listenprivileg, das ist im Paragraph 28 Bundesdatenschutzgesetz, ist sozusagen eine Ausnahme vom Verbot, oder von einer Ausnahme dessen, dass man nicht überall einwilligen muss, sondern dass man sozusagen einmal seine Daten abgeben kann und die dürfen dann weiter gehandelt werden. Damit darf also Datenhandel betrieben werden.
Das ist dieses Listenprivileg.
Also es ist sozusagen ein Privileg, mit Daten handeln zu dürfen, was normalerweise nicht zulässig ist.
Das können Firmen sich sozusagen beschaffen?
Genau. Und das sollte, das war jetzt in der Diskussion bei der letzten Datenschutzenwelle, dass das abgeschafft wird. Das haben aber wohl auf Druck dieser Firmen, haben die das dann doch nicht gemacht. Und das ist also von Bürgerrecht dann eigentlich schon lange eine Forderung, dass wir das Listenprivileg abgeschafft haben. Das würden natürlich einigen Firmen die Geschäftsgrundlage entziehen, was nun mal aber dann eben so ist. Das ist halt, wenn man ein politisches Willen, dann will man es. Und das ist halt der Punkt. Also das ist die, was beim Datenbrief immer gesagt wird, ist, dass genau diese Datenhandelei, die soll erschwert werden. Und da sag ich halt, die soll nicht erschwert werden, sondern die soll am besten ganz kaputt gemacht werden. Und da wäre halt eben die Streikung des Listenprivilegs, dass eigentlich das Mittel der ersten Wahl und nicht der Datenbrief.
Wobei, ich muss mal kurz da reingehen. Es ist nicht so, dass wir diesen Datenhandel als erstes damit bekämpfen wollen oder eindämmen wollen, sondern wir wollen einfach die Bürger informieren, wer diese Daten hat. Und wir wollen vor allem die Datenhaltung, also die langfristige, unsinnige Datenhaltung, wollen wir vermindern. Das heißt also, dass man sich einfach überlegt, was sind sinnvolle Löschfristen? Wie lange brauche ich die Daten wirklich? Sodass es auch so eine Abwägung gibt. Zwischen einerseits diesen Lagerkosten, die wir künstlich erzeugen, also eine 2 Terabyte Festplatte, wo irgendwie alle Bürger der Bundesrepublik fünfmal raufgehen. Das ist kein Problem, die Lagerung. Sondern was wir machen wollen, ist einfach einen künstlichen Lagerwert oder so was, oder halt diese Lagerung verteuern.
Ja, nur ich glaube eben, dass man damit eben sozusagen wirklich nur als Richtige sind eben diese Datenhändler, die man damit wirklich treffen würde. Ansonsten trifft man meines Erachtens die Falschen, weil alle anderen Daten, die außerhalb von solchen Datenhändlern, die vorgehalten werden, sind ja eigentlich, sofern sie nicht missbraucht werden, haben sie ihren legitimen Zweck.
Nein, das ist ja eine falsche Annahme. Nur ein Missbrauch ist ja nicht unbedingt ein Worst Case Szenario. Die Daten sind einfach im letzten Jahr in so großer Masse weggekommen, dass CD's irgendwo gefunden worden sind, Festplatten weggekommen sind, dass Datenbanken von außen einsichtbar gewesen. So ein Datenbrief wird die Datenhygiene einfach fördern in einer Firma, die dann dafür sorgt, dass diese Daten stumpf nach einem Jahr nicht mehr rumliegen, weil wäre zu teuer. Und damit können sie dann auch nicht wegkommen. Und das ist eigentlich auch im Interesse der Firma, dass denen das nächste Mal nicht ein großer PR-Skandal auf die Hüse fällt.
Ja, okay, das mag sein. Das Problem ist, dass es ja gesetzliche Speicherfristen gibt, die in der Regel bei Unternehmen zehn Jahre lang, auch aus steuerlichen Gründen, müssen ja sämtliche Vorgänge aufheben. Also da würde man sozusagen mit einer Verteuerung, die können das ja gar nicht säubern, weil die Gesetze so verfältigt sind.
Also die Vorgänge müssen natürlich nicht zehn Jahre in einem aktiven Datenbestand gehalten werden, sondern du musst die irgendwo abheften. Und über gegen abgeheftet Rechnungsdaten, das sind keine aktiven Daten, die man wirklich im täglichen Geschäftsverkehr benutzt, sondern das sind passive Daten. Die muss man vorhalten. Solange man sie nicht im täglichen Geschäftsbetrieb durch eine Datenbankabfrage auf einem Knopfdruck hervorrufen kann, solange ist es auch nicht Bestandteil des Datenbriefs.
Okay, gut, aber da frage ich mich dann letztlich in der tatsächlichen Durchsetzung oder Umsetzung des Datenbriefes, wenn man jetzt sozusagen in aktive und passive Datenhaltung unterscheiden muss, wäre es dann nicht auch einfacher zu sagen, dann müssen die Daten eben sozusagen eine Pflicht zu machen, dass sie ausreichend geschützt werden.
Das wäre natürlich sowieso sehr wünschenswert.
Das ist Pflicht, aber...
Aber die Trennung in aktive und passive Datenhaltung passiert eh schon. Das Rechnungswesen in der Firma ist ja meistens auch ausgelagert. Man kann es ja versuchen, irgendwo mal anzurufen und dann auf den Rechnung zuzugreifen. Da haben dann die Berater üblicherweise keinen Zugriff, sondern müssen sich in die Rechnungsabteilung weiter vermitteln. Das ist auch ganz gut so.
Ja, und wer bleibt denn dann am Ende übrig? Nehmen wir mal an, wir streichen das Listenprivileg und die meisten halten sich an diese Passive. Wer bleibt denn dann noch übrig? Wer kommt denn dann noch in Frage für diese Datenbriefe?
Okay, jetzt glaube ich, entsteht gerade ein kleines Missverständnis, was aktive und passive Datenhaltung angeht. Und ich würde auch sagen, wenn wir das erklärt haben, dauert es noch mal ein bisschen, deswegen machen wir das nach den Nachrichtenwörter und Verkehr. Es gibt vorher ein kleines bisschen Musik, dann machen wir Nachrichtenwörter und Verkehr, dann geht es weiter um den Datenbrief und ihr könnt weiterhin anrufen unter der 0331 70 97 110.
Ja, davon haben wir hier jede Menge. In dieser Woche gibt es bei Fritz jede Menge Karten, für jede Menge Festivals zu gewinnen. Zum Beispiel für Splash, Hurricanes, Highfield, Rock im Paar, Melt, Jigget, Berlin-Festivals.
Und das sind längst noch nicht alle.
Und im Radio dazu jede Menge Karten für jede Menge Festivals.
Mit denen kommt man da rein.
Und das hört man um kurz nach halb elf. Nachrichten. In Berlin könnten am 1. Mai rund 1500 Rechtsextremisten demonstrieren. Mit dieser Zahl rechnet der Berliner Verfassungsschutz. Er sagt, dass die Rechtsextremisten in den letzten Monaten mit Plakaten flyern und deutschlandweit im Internet für ihre Demo geworben haben. Nach Einschätzung von Innsanto Kurting könnten es noch mehr Teilnehmer werden, wenn rechte Demos in anderen Bundesländern verboten werden. Griechenland braucht, wie es aussieht, noch mehr Geld. Bundeswirtschaftsminister Brüderle sprach am Nachmittag von 135 Milliarden Euro für die nächsten drei Jahre. Bisher war von 45 Milliarden die Rede. Auch Deutschland muss offenbar mehr Geld für Griechenland zur Verfügung stellen als geplant. Nicht 8, sondern mindestens 25 Milliarden Euro soll der deutsche Anteil betragen. Im Kampf gegen die Ölpest im Golf von Mexiko haben Experten damit begonnen, den Ölteppich in Brand zu stecken. Damit soll verhindert werden, dass sich das Öl weiter ausbreitet. Es ist noch etwa 30 Kilometer von der amerikanischen Südküste entfernt. Auch heute klappte es nicht, die Lex an der gesunkenen Bohrinsel zu schließen. Bayern München spielt im Champions League Finale offenbar gegen Inter Mailand. Im Rückspiel heute Abend konnte das Team aus Barcelona den Hinspielrückstand nicht mehr aufholen. Die Partie endet in diesen Minuten. Und vor etwa einer Minute ist da noch ein Tor gefallen. Es steht jetzt eins zu null für Barcelona. Das reicht allerdings nicht aus, um den Rückstand, wie ich gerade gesagt habe, aufzuholen. Im Champions League Finale wird dann Bayerns der Franke Berri fehlen. Die UEFA hat ihn für drei Spiele gesperrt. Und noch eine Meldung vom Basketball. Aber Berlin hat sich in der Basketball-Bundesliga auf den dritten Tabellenplatz verbessert. Das Team besiegt am Abend Bremerhaven nach hartem Kampf mit 74 zu 73. Heute Nacht bleibt es trocken. Meistens ist es auch sternenklar im Sendegebiet. Die Temperaturen liegen zwischen 5 bis 9 Grad. Hier sind die aktuellen Werte. Es ist noch ziemlich mild draußen. Neuropeen, das sind 12 Grad. Potsdam, Frankfurt, Cottbus, Angermünde 13. Wittenberge 14. Berlin zwischen 13 und 15 Grad. Morgen gibt es wieder ein Vorgeschmack auf den Sommer. Es wird wieder schön warm und sonnig werden. Mit Temperaturen zwischen 23 und 26 Grad. Wir haben uns troffen allerdings, am Wochenende wird es dann nicht mehr ganz so schön sein. Es gibt dann wieder mehr Wolken und es wird wieder deutlich kühler werden. Bitte Vorsicht auf der A24 Berlin Richtung Hamburg. Zwischen Raststätte Weißleben Ost und Herzsprung da ist die linke Spur wegen Bauarbeiten gesperrt. Außerdem gibt es an vielen Stellen des Stadtkriegs noch ein paar Probleme, da müsst ihr mit Verzögerungen rechnen. Und es gibt eine Störung im Regionalverkehr. Die Linie RE1 ist zwischen der Fangschleus und Fürstenwalde unterbrochen. Stattdessen fahren dort Busse. Die Störung wird wahrscheinlich noch bis morgen Mittag dauern. Da haben ja Diebe die Oberlandleitung beschädigt und da ist das Material geklaut. Euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBW.
Dann Fritz in Eisenhüttenstadt.
Mit Markus Richter und Erdgeist und Frank Rosengard, der gerade nicht an seinem Telefon, an seinem Mikrofon ist, der jetzt auch nochmal diesen kleinen Knopf tab betätigen müsste. Hey, alle wieder da im Chaos Blumun am letzten Mittwoch im Monat bei Fritz. Und wir reden hier über den Datenbrief. Kannst du noch mal kurz eine Zusammenfassung geben, was das ist?
Der Datenbrief ist eine Art Datenkontoauszug, das heißt, dass mich Firmen und Behörden, die Daten über mich gespeichert haben, persönliche Daten über mich gespeichert haben, mich einmal im Jahr informieren sollen, dass sie diese Daten haben und was sie da haben.
So, und jetzt haben wir gerade schon festgestellt, es gibt viele Komplikationen und es gibt vor allen Dingen auch Kritik an dem Datenbrief, unter anderem vom Blockfürsten, der hier am Telefon ist. Hallo und guten Abend nochmal. Und wir waren vor den Nachrichten dabei stehengeblieben, dass es irgendwie einen Unterschied zwischen aktiver und passiver Datenhaltung gibt. Was genau ist das?
Also wir verstehen darunter, dass Daten, die hier zum täglichen, also das ist, muss ich auch dazu sagen, das ist ein Punkt, wo wir jetzt tatsächlich in die Feinarbeit gehen müssen, um so was zu definieren. Und wenn ihr nicht, sag ich mal, Geschäftsleute seid oder mit, sag ich nicht, Rechnungen ausstellt, gewerblich tätig seid, dann ist das wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen fremd alles. Aber es gibt eine Abgabenordnung, sprich, es ist eine Vorgabe vom Finanzamt, dass man Rechnungsdaten, Geschäftsunterlagen aufbewahren muss. Und zwar zehn Jahre. Und die müssen archiviert werden, rechtssicher archiviert werden. Und da müsste es ja dann so sein, dass mit diesem Datenbrief zehn Jahre lang immer der gleiche Datenbrief kommt, zu entsprechender Aufbewahrungspflichten, Steuergesetz, blablabla, müssen wir folgende Daten haben, wir folgen Daten und müssen sie noch die nächsten sechs Jahre aufbewahren. Das ist natürlich nicht hilfreich. Und deswegen müssen wir überlegen, wie wir bei Firmen, bei Unternehmern diese Daten trennen können. Einerseits sind diese archivierten Daten, die man wirklich ablegt und die dann am besten irgendwo, das ist nicht ausgedruckt, abgeheftet, irgendwo ins Archiv gestellt sind. Und die, die wirklich in einer Datenbank drin sind, wo ich darauf zugreifen kann, die vielleicht mal im Online-Shop-System sind, wo ich irgendwie Werbebriefe mit verschicke, wo irgendwie irgendwelche Berechnungen mit gemacht werden. Also so aktive Daten, also Daten, die wirklich in Benutzung sind. Das ist die Idee dabei, dass wir da unterscheiden. Das ist in der Praxis, wird es schwierig, das wissen wir. Und da sind wir natürlich jetzt auch für jeden Input dankbar, wie man diese Trennung in der Praxis machen könnte und wie man sowas auch in ein Gesetz so schreiben kann, dass sich Firmen denn nicht rauswinden können und sagen, naja, wir haben die Daten ja archiviert.
Also ich frage mich halt, wenn jetzt halt sozusagen jeder Geschäftstreibende, indem er die Daten passiv ablegt. Hab ich das richtig verstanden, dass man sich damit von dem Datenbrief zu Freiden von der Pflicht?
Die Idee ist ja, dass du mit dem Datenbrief die Asymmetrie, die zwischen Firmen und dem Kunden besteht, dass Firmen über dich Dinge wissen, die du nicht weißt, dass sie sie über dich wissen, diese Asymmetrie kannst du sofort dadurch aufheben, dass die Rechnung verschickt wird. Dann steht da nämlich genau das drauf, was die Firma auch weiß. Wenn du genau das abheftest, dann haben beide Seiten diese Information und es gibt irgendwie keinen Grund mehr, wegen dieser Rechnung, wegen dieser einen Transaktion weiterhin einen Datenbrief zu verschicken. Wenn du diesen Kunden aber weiterhin in deiner Datenbank führst und mit ihm ein aktives Kundenverhältnis beibehältst, dann würde der Kunde informiert werden müssen.
Okay, gut. Dann stellt sich bei mir die Frage, das heißt also, die aktive Kundenbindung, Datenvorhaltung soll sozusagen teurer gemacht werden. Jetzt ist es ja in vielen, gerade bei vielen geschäftlichen Bereichen, die Frage, ob das gewünscht ist. Zum einen sind das ja Kosten, die letztlich natürlich wieder nur der Kunde zahlt, weil die Kosten werden halt umgeschlagen. Zum anderen frage ich mich halt, für mich ist das ein bisschen eine Zwangsbeglückung. Also 80 Millionen Bundesbürger kriegen so einen Datenbrief. Ich finde es wesentlich zielsicherer, wenn man sozusagen jedem das Recht einräumt, dass er so einen Datenbrief anfordern kann.
Das haben wir ja schon.
Ja, gut, das ist aber in der Praxis, wissen wir ja, dass das kaum, dass das ein zahnloser Tiger ist.
Nein, das ist kein zahnloser Tiger, sondern es funktioniert deswegen nicht, weil die Leute erstens nicht wissen, dass sie die Möglichkeit haben, das zu tun, und zweitens gar nicht wissen, dass irgendjemand da Daten über sie hat. Und dass die vielleicht möglicherweise viel spannender sind, die Daten, als man das annimmt.
Gut, das ist halt eine Frage, wenn man halt jetzt sagt, man will unbedingt alle darüber informieren, wer halt welche Daten über sie hat, dann würde ich jetzt mal behaupten, dass vielleicht viele diese Information nicht haben wollen. Und wenn man dann sozusagen trotzdem jedem diese Daten schickt und wenn das Argument auch der Missbrauch ist, um den Missbrauch zu verhindern, also bei so vielen Datenbriefen, die versendet werden, da werden auch sehr viele wahrscheinlich an falsche Adressen gelangen. Und dann ist wieder das Argument, da sind mit Sicherheit auch Sensibildaten dabei und die, wenn die in falsche Hände geraten, ist der Schaden so möglich größer, wie der Nutzen, den man durch den Datenbrief zieht.
Das ist auch eine Frage, die wird häufiger mal gestellt. Was ist denn, wenn die Daten falsch kommen? Da wird im Chat auch gerade darüber diskutiert, kann doch sein, dass, wie sollten das sich hergestellt werden?
Naja, also dass die Daten falsch sind, das ist ja die Idee davon, das aufzudecken, wenn Daten falsch sind. Die Frage ist, ob sie falsch zugestellt werden. Aber wenn wir uns mal die Statistiken anschauen, wie viele Briefe wirklich falsch zugestellt werden und dann auch tatsächlich aufgemacht werden, wie viele E-Mails falsch zugestellt werden. Ja, gut, das kann auch mal mit einem Paket passieren.
Ja, ich bezog mich jetzt eigentlich nicht weniger darauf, dass die Post falsch zugestellt wird, sondern einfach, blödes Beispiel, ich bestelle jetzt hier mir irgendwie eine Puppe im Beate-Use-Sex-Job und dann als Familienvater und dann kommt dann der Brief hier rein, es ist gut zu sagen, wir haben ihre Daten hier, wenn Beate-Use-Sex und dann ist die Ehe, das steht dann voll im Haus.
Also was wir ausdrücklich vorsehen, ist die Möglichkeit eines Opt-Out. Das heißt also eine Möglichkeit zu sagen, ein Häkchen, ein Kästchen, was man setzen kann. Nein, ich verzichte auf den Brief, danke, das muss nicht sein.
Und zudem hast du dir die Puppe ja auch erstmal in deine Privatadresse schicken lassen, was dann vielleicht im Nachhinein eine blöde Idee gewesen ist. Und musst dann halt deine Datenhygiene betreiben. Aber ich fände es wie besser, dass ich Bescheid weiß, dass da dieser Händler vielleicht selber und irgendwie noch seine ganzen Partnerfirmen diese Informationen, dass diese Puppe bestellt hat, dass ich auch endlich Bescheid weiß, wer da irgendwie noch alles drüber weiß, als wenn es mir dann plötzlich mal ganz überraschend auf die Früße fällt.
Na gut, das ist ja wieder das Argument, was gegen, also für die Streikung des Listenprivilegs. Immer dieses Argument mit das andere noch, das ist ja immer, dass diese Datenwai- tergabel basiert ja immer auf dem Listenprivileg. Wenn man das abschaffen würde, würde in meinen Augen schon ein sehr, sagen wir mal, ein sehr großer Teil der Anwendungsbereiche von Datenbriefs wegfallen. Also das ist ja wirklich das große Übel, wenn man das Listenprivileg wegmacht. Das wäre dann in meinen Augen nicht mehr da. Ich denke halt nur, es ist irgendwie, ja wie gesagt, also Zwangsbegrüßung, dass man sagt, ob's out, warum macht man es nicht umgekehrt, ob's in? Und ich hatte auch mal das Argument, was ich gehört habe ist, aber ich weiß ja nicht, wo ich überall mal, also das hatte ich auch in einem anderen Blog mal gehört, hat jemand gesagt, ich weiß so nicht, wo ich in den letzten zehn Jahren überall mich angemeldet hab.
Dann weißt es.
Ja, aber dann muss ich doch mal sagen, aber das ist doch nicht das Verschulden, sag ich jetzt mal, der Gesellschaft. Sondern wenn man selber so überall seine Daten rumstreut und das, sag ich jetzt mal, sich nicht notiert oder so, dann kann man doch dafür nicht die Allgemeinheit haftbar machen. Da muss man halt selber einfach ein bisschen aufpassen, wo man sich anmeldet und wenn man das halt sich notiert, dann kann man ja auch, also in meiner Auffassung nach, mit einem durchsetzbaren Auskunftsanspruch, kann man auch überall nachfragen, welche Daten haben sie bei mir. Also das halte ich für praktikabler und auch wird ein bisschen auf dem gerecht, dass man auch selber ein bisschen aufpassen muss, wo man seine Daten hingebt.
Ein Prozess, den wir damit anstoßen wollen, ist, dass in Firmen nachgedacht wird. Einerseits, wie lange müssen diese Daten wirklich gespeichert sein? Andererseits, wenn wir die weitergeben, auf welcher, oder wenn wir überhaupt verarbeiten, auf welche Rechtsgrundlage machen wir das eigentlich? Also welches Gesetz erlaubt uns, das mit diesen Daten zu tun, was wir da eigentlich schon seit Jahren machen? Und das muss in diesem Datenbrief auch drinstehen, auf welcher rechtlichen Grundlage. Das heißt, die Firmen werden erstmalig gezwungen, überhaupt sich mal Gedanken zu machen, warum sie oder mit welcher Erlaubnis sie diese Daten überhaupt verarbeiten oder möglicherweise weitergeben an Dritte. Und das dürfte in einigen Firmen schon für etliche Diskussionen sorgen und dürfte auch schon mal strukturell deutlich was verbessern. Also ich kenne es halt aus der täglichen Praxis, wenn man sagt, ja, wir haben halt da irgendwie die Dateien und was machen wir denn, irgendwann löschen wir die, löscht Fristen, keine Ahnung, wie lange brauchen wir so Daten? So und dann, wenn man mal wirklich darüber informieren muss, das aufschreiben muss und mal ganz offiziell verkünden muss, warum haben wir eigentlich diese Daten und was glauben wir, mit diesen Daten tun zu tun zu dürfen? Und dieser Prozess allein spricht schon dafür, dass wir diesen Datenbrief brauchen.
Also das Argument, das kann ich sehr gut nachvollziehen, dass man hier mal eine Veränderung in dem Denken anstößt, dass das hier wirklich mal nicht lästig ist, Datenschutzbeauftragter brauchen wir nicht. Also das teile ich auf jeden Fall. Und ich kann es auch nachvollziehen, dass man den Datenbrief als Mittel dafür sieht. Ich bin aber der Auffassung, dass man diesen Prozess des Nachdenkens, des vielleicht Änderens, man auch dadurch erreichen kann, und das ist in meinen Augen das mildere Mittel, dass man eben ein Auskunftsrecht einrichtet. Und wenn dann wirklich, es gibt auch genug Leute hier in unserem Land, die das auch regenutzen werden würden, ein kostenloses Auskunftsrecht, die dann überall nachfragen.
Das haben wir.
Und nachhaken und das darbüchtern und dann im Zweifel auch mal ein Prozess führen und da auch mal irgendjemand verurteilt wird oder Bußgelder gezahlt werden müssen, dass das auch schon diese Motivation, sich damit näher umzudenken, dass das schon das umsetzt und das ist aber in meinen Augen das mildere Mittel ist, weil man damit nicht alle...
Ich möchte mal kurz sozusagen, weil wir jetzt auch noch andere Leute in Leitung haben, also im Prinzip, was du forderst, ist ja ein Datenbrief mit Opt-in. Also sagen, das soll schneller und einfacher gehen, als es jetzt gerade der Fall ist. Nämlich günstigstenfalls dadurch, dass ich einfach irgendwo klicke und sage, so, ich will jetzt mal meinen Datenbrief. Und dass man das sozusagen einfacher nutzen kann. Das heißt also sagen, du findest die Idee dahinter okay, du findest auch das Ziel okay, aber die Umsetzung zweifelst du. Und du sagst halt eher, wir bräuchten eher einen Datenbrief mit Opt-in und dann müsste dieses Listenprivileg gestrichen werden und da kommen wir auch genauso weit, wie wenn man nur einen Datenbrief macht. Das ist deine Meinung? Alles klar. Ich denke auch sozusagen, da würde sich jetzt nicht mehr viel ändern, aber es ist schon viel klar geworden, alleine in dieser Diskussion. Ich danke dir auf jeden Fall, dass du mitgemacht hast. Der Blockfürst hat nämlich einen kritischen Artikel über den Datenbrief geschrieben und ich freue mich immer, wenn solche Leute sich dann auch trauen anzurufen. Also, dir einen schönen Abend noch. Bis denn. So, und dann haben wir noch ein paar Leute hier in der Leitung. Ihr könnt gerne auch noch Folgendes tun.
Jetzt anrufen.
Die jede Menge Fragen zum sogenannten Datenbrief haben, zum Beispiel der Jochen. Hallo Jochen.
Ich habe zwar folgende Frage zu dem Thema, wo ich ein bisschen skeptisch draufschaue, die Realisierbarkeit auf finanzieller Ebene von dem Datenbrief.
Von wem?
Von den Firmen?
Nein, allgemein, weil das Ganze muss ja auch irgendwie von Startseiten aus organisiert werden, weil sie haben ja gesagt, man muss alles kontrollieren. Das muss ja alles kontrolliert werden und es fällt ja am Ende alles auf uns Steuerzahler wieder zurück dann.
Also die Steuerzahler betrifft das Fall von Firmen nicht. Da würde es sich eher als Kunden betreffen. Aber am Ende haben Firmen gerade schon Datenschutzbeauftragte, da bestimmten Größe, die die Einhaltung überwachen. Und es ist für so eine Firma natürlich auch mal ein Risiko, sich nicht an die Datenschutzgesetze zu halten, weil auch ein finanzielles Risiko und auch für den Geschäftsführer, der persönlich haftbar gemacht werden kann. Und die Überwachung kann er übrigens noch nicht.
Das wäre auch noch eine Forderung von uns. Aber okay, weiter.
Und die Überwachung obliegt natürlich der Firma, dem Datenschutzbeauftragten, die das eh schon tot. Also da kommen keine größeren Kosten durch die Überwachung auf die Gesellschaft zu. Man könnte vielleicht argumentieren, dass durch das Versenden von Datenbriefen, die vorher nicht hätten versendet werden sollen, dort Kosten auf die Firma zukommen. Aber eine Firma, die einen regen Kundenkontakt mit ihrem aktiven Kundenstamm führt, schreibt da vielleicht Kaufempfehlungen eh einmal pro Jahr und kann dabei dann einfach auch noch einen Fallblatt mit einem Datenbrief reintun.
Das ist übrigens, was auch in einem Wiki eine Frage ist, also ihr habt das ja vorhin auch schon mal angebracht, da kann man ja einfach noch irgendwie einen bunten Zettel reinpacken. Ist das nicht doch sozusagen Anleitung zu noch mehr Spam? Also vor allem, so Kaufwürfe, so ach naja irgendwie, hier was hat er geschrieben, diese Kaffeehausfirma, da könnt ihr auch mal wieder was bestellen, hat ihr eh mal eine Datenhöhe, kann ich ja gleich mal hier so ein Angebot...
Ja, ok, drehen wir die Sache um. Wenn die Firmen eh schon alle drei Monate mal was schicken, dann können sie auch bei jedem vierten Brief dann das Dateninfo beiliegen. Also, nein, das ist natürlich keine Einladung, jetzt dann noch zusätzlich was zu schicken, aber ich denke, dass Firmen da einen kreativen Umgang finden und ich denke auch, dass von Gesetzgeberseite da durchaus einen Weg gefunden werden kann, um die Belastung für die Firmen möglichst gering zu halten und ihm andererseits sogar einen Anreiz zu geben, dann sozusagen diesen Datenbrief als Anlass zu nehmen, in positiven Kunden Kontakt zu treten und die Kunden anzusprechen und sagen, übrigens, wir freuen uns, dass sie schon so lange Kunde sind und in der Zeit kann sich auch viel ändern. Hier haben wir ihre Daten, schauen noch mal, ob alles in Ordnung ist. Wenn nicht, dann freuen wir uns auf die andere Nachricht, auf ihren Anruf.
Ja, aber ihr seht das halt ziemlich kritisch auch mit der Datenüberwachung und das müsste man auch ziemlich kritisch sehen. Also wenn man das wirklich durchziehen möchte mit dem Datenbrief, das müsste man auch ziemlich kritisch sehen, weil da fallen schon ziemlich Kosten an, weil die extreme Überwachung auch von kleinen Firmen müsste dann gewährleistet sein, weil es kann ja nicht nur sein, dass nur die ganz großen Firmen an einer bestimmten Anzahl an gesammelten Daten da irgendwie überprücht werden. Ich finde das, also ich weiß nicht, weil die kleinen Firmen, ja so klein wie viel macht auch nichts.
Also ist derzeit finden halt stichprobenartig eh schon von den Datenschutzbeauftragten des Landes bei Firmen Kontrollen statt, um zu gucken, ob es da Abläufe gibt, wie diese Abläufe aussehen, wie man sicherstellt, dass die Datenschutzgesetze eingehalten werden und das passiert auch weiterhin. Aber du hast natürlich auch als Bürger, wenn du einen Verdacht hast, wenn du plötzlich Post von irgendwo bekommst, da einfach bei deinem Landesdatenschutzbeauftragten Bescheid zu sagen und zu sagen, na bei der Firma da riecht irgendwas ganz streng, geh mal da vorbei. Aber es ist nicht so, dass jetzt alle Firmen einzelnen ständig total überwacht werden. Ist ja sonst auch nicht. Wir wollen die Firmen nicht unter Generalverdacht stellen, sondern die Firmen müssen einfach, wenn sie anfangen, Daten zu sammeln, also wenn sie sich selber aus der Deckung wagen, dann müssen sie auch ganz offen damit umgehen.
Also Eintragung sozusagen über solche Firmen geben. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es das schon gibt.
Aber halt komplett. Bist du wie beim Gammelfleisch oder so? Dass denn die Firmen geoutet werden, die das nicht einhalten?
Nein, nein, nein. So meint ich das nicht. Ich meinte das eher so, dass es Listen, intern Listen vom Staat ausgeben sollte. Also nicht öffentlich einsehbar, sondern Listen vom Staat aus, dass der Staat weiß, wer Datensammlung betreibt, also wer Daten sammelt und dass dort dann auch strichpro-artig kontrolliert werden kann. Ich meine, okay, es wird fast überall werden Daten gesammelt. Das ist auch normal. Das gehört einfach dazu und darauf bauen auch ziemlich viele Branchen auf die Datensammlung, zum Beispiel die Werbung unter anderem. Und ja, man sieht es halt auch ziemlich viel im Internet. Es wird halt viel, also ziemlich unbewusst. Wenn ich mich zum Beispiel irgendwo anmelde, ich weiß es gerade nicht, auf irgendeiner Seite, dann habe ich ja automatisch, dann tue ich mich ja direkt anmelden und zustimmen. Diese AGBs, die liest so gut wie niemand, weil die immer meistens ein paar Seiten lang sind oder sowas.
Das ist ja auch einer der Gründe, warum deine Adressen plötzlich irgendwo auftauchen, wo du nicht damit rechnest, weil du unten das ganze Kleingedruckte mit unterschrieben hast, ohne das zu merken. Da ist natürlich auch ein positiver Aspekt, dass die Firmen, die dich dort dann übertöpelt haben, in einer Fußgängerzone irgendwo, wo du was unterschrieben hast, dass diese Firmen dann wirklich angehalten werden, dir Bescheid zu sagen, und dass du dann wieder da hergehen kannst und sagst, nee, ich will das nicht, mach mal irgendwie die Daten da sofort weg.
Aber ich finde, das Ausmaß, ihr habt vorhin so von circa 100 Datenbriefen gesprochen, also ich für mich selber, ich bin ein ziemlich starker PC-Nutzer und ich melde mich ziemlich oft irgendwo an und solche Sachen, das Ausmaß, das wäre extrem in manchen Fällen.
Heißt das, zwei Mal in der Woche dich eine Firma informiert darüber, meistens per E-Mail und meistens in Kundenkontakt, die sie eh mit dir haben? Also ich glaube nicht, dass das Aufkommen durch den Datenbrief dann viel, viel größer wird.
Okay, also du hast ja gerade auch schon gesagt, von wegen, dass der Staat dann irgendwie mit den Firmen zusammen regeln wird, damit nicht allzu viele Kosten für die Firmen selbst anfallen. Ich weiß nicht, dass das fällt da am Ende dann auch wieder auf den Staat alles zurück. Da müsste man auch schauen, wie das läuft. Es gibt ja wirklich Firmen, die sind wirklich nur auf der Ansammlung ausgelegt. Die arbeiten damit, die handeln mit Daten, das ist ihr Geschäft.
Genau, und für die soll es teuer werden.
Ja genau, aber wenn es für die richtig teuer wird, dann stirbt sozusagen auch wieder eine Branche aus.
Ja, aber das ist eine Branche, mit der ich ganz ehrlich gesagt jetzt nicht so allergrößt ist mitleite.
Aber die dazu gehört, die Branche gehört dazu und Werbung basiert da auch darauf. So ist es einfach.
Man kann auch Werbung treiben, ohne jetzt sprunghaften Datenhandel zu treiben. Also das geht auch schon so, aber es geht ja auch nicht darum, dass wir diese Firmen ganz abschaffen wollen. Wir wollen es halt ein kleines bisschen transparenter machen für den Kunden.
Also das, das, ja, okay, ich verstehe schon. Ich will schon, ich, so ein Datenbrief finde ich schon gut. Aber ich finde, man sollte die Datenbriefe, finde ich, sollte man auf Größe dann so zum Beispiel einschränken, dass zum Beispiel irgendwie der Datenschutz strenger gemacht wird, dass zum Beispiel die meine Daten, manche kleinere Firmen, ja, die nicht speziell in die Branche, in der Branche sind, ja, dass die meine Daten nur so und so lange speichern dürfen. Ich denke da jetzt circa an ein Jahr oder so was. Und also, sofern ich dort nicht mehr aktiv bin bei denen, also, wenn das eine einmalige Sache war, ja.
Das passiert auch dann automatisch. Dann können sich diese Firmen überlegen, lösche ich diese Daten jetzt oder schicke ich dir den Brief? Und dann müssen sie schauen, ob es denen das gerade wert ist, dichterweit an ihrer Kundendatenbank zu halten. Und wenn nicht, können sie die Daten auch einfach löschen.
Ja, aber das machen ja ziemlich wenig, weil...
Weil es kostet nichts.
Ja, bei diesen Opt-in, das habe ich ja... Opt-in bedeutet ja praktisch, ich stimme zu, damit sie mit meinen Daten handeln dürfen. Und warum sollten sie mich aus der Datenbank rauslöschen, wenn ich sozusagen Bargeld für die bin, wenn meine Daten, wenn die Bargeld für die sind? Weil es gibt ja auch Firmen, an die das dann verkauft wird.
Ich glaube jetzt können wir uns langsam im Kreis, weil die Idee hinter dem Datenbrief ist ja gerade, dass du kein Bargeld mehr für die bist, weil dann diese Datenhaltung genau Geld kostet. Das heißt, du bist zwar noch Bargeld, aber möglicherweise Negatives. So, eine Frage, die ich gerade stellen wollte, die ich aber gerade vergessen habe, war, doch mit den kleinen Firmen. Es ist jetzt schon vorstellbar. Es gibt jetzt, sagen wir mal, hypothetisches Beispiel, das kann man bestimmt auch wieder zerschießen, aber es ist in der Tat denkbar, dass es ganz kleine Firmen gibt.
Kleiner Sportverein.
Kleiner Sportverein oder kleiner Versandhändler.
Das Problem, das sind halt meistens die Schlimmsten. Inwiefern? Dass einfach gerade ein kleiner Sportverein hat auf dem PC eine Datenbank und der PC ist am Internet und sind diese Daten mal irgendwie weg. Oder sie haben die auf einer Homepage oder so. Es gab ein ziemlicher Aufruhr, dass es ein Fußballverein gibt.
Ich wollte nicht darauf hinaus, dass jemand, der Schindl oder treibt, dann durch den Datenbrief dazu genötigt wird, das besser zu machen. Sondern wir gehen jetzt mal von einem Positivbeispiel aus. Es gibt da einen kleinen Typen, der hat halt irgendwie einen kleinen Versandhandel oder macht einen Sportverein, achtet aber darauf, dass die Daten sicher verpackt sind. Trotzdem entsteht jetzt durch den Datenbrief ein finanzieller Mehraufwand, der irgendwie geleistet werden muss. Ist eine Ausnahmeregelung vorgesehen oder sagt ihr dann, wir müssen das für alle machen, gleiches Recht für alle, das muss gelten?
Ne, also es sollte aus meiner Sicht keine Ausnahmeregelung für kleine Firmen oder kleine Vereine geben. Weil diese Daten sind ja trotzdem genauso da und für die ist es ja meist umso einfacher, diese Leute zu informieren. Oder andersherum, also warum sollten die dann die Daten nicht löschen? Also die Idee ist ja, dass die Daten gar nicht lange aufbewahrt werden, wenn sie nicht benötigt werden.
Ja, weil das ist gerade bei einem Verein, das ist schon ein bisschen schwierig, weil natürlich will ich die Vereinsleute sozusagen jedes Jahr zur ordentlichen Vorstandssitzung einladen.
Genau, dann kommt einfach auf das Einladungsbrief, kommt drauf. Übrigens wir haben diese Daten, das macht der CCC seit Jahren so, da heißt es nicht Datenbrief, aber trotzdem steht auf jeder Einladung zur Mitgliederversammlung. Übrigens, wir haben folgende Daten über dich gespeichert.
Okay, damit ist das alles erledigt. Gut, na schauen wir mal, ob die anderen Leute auch dieser Ansicht sind. Ihr könnt nämlich folgendes tun. Jetzt anrufen! 0331 70 97 110 Und während ihr euch die Finger wundt, hören wir hier ein bisschen Musik. Hey Leute, wollte Musik hören, die Creative Commons Musik ist. Creative Commons Musik ist Musik, die man sich runterladen kann und die man auch weitergeben kann. Das ist hier nicht ganz der Fall, aber ich fand den Namen der Band so schön. But then the self in the tree fell asleep heißt diese Band und Trash Song kann man unterladen. Die haben irgendwie ganzen Alben online gestellt. Den Link dazu gibt es auch im Wiki zur Sendung unter chaosradio.de. Heute das Chaos Radio, moderiert von Markus Richter, das bin ich und den beiden Typen, die hier komisch am Computer rumklappen und immer vergessen an den Mikrofon zu gehen, namentlich Frank Rofengardt.
Hallo.
Und Erdgeist.
Einsatzverpasst.
Und es geht heute um den Datenbrief. Der Datenbrief ist eine Idee, wo es kurz gesagt darum geht, dass Firmen die Daten über euch haben, euch einmal Bescheid sagen, welche Daten sie haben. Es gibt so Feinheiten daran, die haben wir schon am Anfang der Sendung geklärt. Wir würden jetzt nicht normal nachholen, weil dann wäre die zweite Stunde sozusagen genauso wie die erste. Aber wenn ihr dazu Fragen habt, könnt ihr entweder anrufen 0331 77 97 110 oder euch heute Nacht noch den Podcast dieser Sendung auf fritz.de anhören. So, es geht wie gesagt um den Datenbrief und es gibt da ein paar Fragen, zum Beispiel von Tim. Hallo Tim.
Ja, so nach dem, was ich jetzt gehört habe, sehe ich das relativ kritisch mit dem Datenbrief. Ich bin sonst eigentlich immer recht begeistert von den Ideen, die so aus dem CCC-Umfeld kommen. Allerdings hier sehe ich eigentlich einfach unheimlich viele Kollateralschäden und eigentlich keinen wirklichen Sinn, keinen wirklichen Vorteil. Denn in dem Moment, wo ich, wo ich halt mitkriege, dass irgendjemand meine Daten benutzt, dass ich irgendeinen Werbebrief bekomme, dass ich also irgendwie davon betroffen bin, dass ich, dass sozusagen meine Daten missbraucht werden oder genutzt werden, wie ich das nicht will, habe ich ja auch jetzt schon das Auskunftsrecht und kann ja auch beantragen, diese Daten zu löschen. Ich sehe aber einfach, dass es sehr viele Menschen gibt, die dies einfach gar nicht so kritisch finden, dass ihre Daten überall gespeichert sind. Ich zum Beispiel habe eigentlich überhaupt kein Problem damit und möchte eigentlich auch gerne das Unternehmen möglichst viel über mich wissen, weil sie mich dann eigentlich auch am besten betreuen können. Und sehe es einfach kritisch, dass ich dann sicherlich mehrere hundert Briefe bekommen würde, wo ich mir dann die Arbeit machen würde, wahrscheinlich überall zu sagen, hier bitte schickt mir nicht diese ganzen Briefe und diesen ganzen Spam. Und sehe auch einfach gigantische Kosten, die da auf Unternehmen zukommen, also gerade auch auf kleinere Unternehmen, die ihre IT einfach gar nicht in einem Zustand haben, wo sie sowas leisten können. Also letztendlich sehe ich einfach unheimlich viele Kollateralschäden und sehe einfach unheimlich viel Nervpotenzial, sage ich mal, bei Menschen, die einfach auch gar nicht wissen wollen, was alles über sie gespeichert sind, die das Thema halt nicht so interessiert, wie das eben in diesem TTC-Kontext der Fall ist, wo man eben diese Datenspeicherung generell relativ kritisch sieht.
Das ist jetzt so ein bisschen so der Facebook-Ansatz. Privatsphäre, ach, ist doch Vergangenheit. Du hast natürlich auf jeden Fall die Möglichkeit, einfach das Häkchen zu setzen, sagen, ich interessiert mich nicht, mach doch was ihr wollt. Ich glaube aber nicht, dass die Großteil der Bürger so denkt. Viele werden schon mal neugierig sein, werden dann vielleicht irgendwann sagen, ja gut, jetzt weiß ich es einmal. Vielleicht wird sich es auch so einpaneln, dass die Firmen entsprechend ihre Datenmengen zurückfahren. Das heißt, dass sich das so ein bisschen selbst reguliert und dass wir vielleicht auch irgendwann gar nicht mehr den Datenbrief brauchen, weil die Firmen einfach von sich aus ganz knapp und sparsam mit den Daten umgehen. Im Moment ist es aber nicht der Fall. Im Moment sind da unglaubliche Mengen an Daten angehäuft und es betrifft ja auch nicht nur Firmen, sondern auch Behörden und da wird es dann wahrscheinlich auch noch mal richtig spannend, was die über mich haben. Wir haben das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz. Es wird leider auch kaum genutzt. Es wird von den Firmen, von den Behörden, Entschuldigung, auch ganz massiv verhindert, dass es benutzt wird. Es gibt das Auskunftsrecht nach BDSG. Es wird auch kaum genutzt, weil es auch sehr umständlich ist. Und ich muss natürlich auch als Bürger wirklich auch erst mal nachforschen. Es gibt auch die Möglichkeit, ein öffentliches Verfahrensverzeichnis einzusehen, wenn die Firmen das haben, wo also beschrieben wird, was für Datenverarbeitungsvorgänge sie machen. Wir haben eigentlich schon eine ganze Menge Möglichkeiten. Es hilft mir aber alles dann nicht, wenn ich nicht weiß, wer Daten über mich hat. So und das ist die Idee vom Datenbrief.
Aber die stört sich ja auch quasi nicht, solange diese Daten nicht genutzt werden. Also in dem Moment, wo du gar nicht weißt, wer deine Daten hat und solange der nichts macht mit diesen Daten, bist du ja eigentlich auch nicht betroffen. Aber in dem Moment, wo du es weißt, kannst du ja halt, kannst du ja nachfragen und kannst ja auch sagen, ok, löscht diese Daten, wenn ihr nicht wollt oder wenn ich nicht will, dass die genutzt werden.
Wir hatten letztes Jahr so ein Fall auf dem Kongress, da sind die Daten von Thor Steiner abhandengekommen. So teilweise Bestelldaten von echt lange her und dann wurden die im Internet veröffentlicht und dann hatten da ein paar Leute, die national gesinnt sind, plötzlich Besuch und hätten die vorher gewusst, dass Thor Steiner da auch noch Jahre nach der Bestellung sie als aktiven Datenbestand in der Datenbank behält, dann hätten die wahrscheinlich da angerufen und gesagt, mach mal weg. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass nur wirklich Missbrauch von irgendjemand ganz Bösen dann zum Schlimmsten führt. Aber manchmal hast du einfach so plötzlich schlechte Scoringwerte. Du möchtest irgendwie wo bestellen und dann hast du ewig Trouble, weil du nicht mit Kreditkarte und nur auf Vorkasse bezahlen kannst und bestimmte Dinge einfach nicht machen kannst. Da hättest du schon gerne gewusst, woran das jetzt liegt. Wer da welche Daten über dich zusammengeführt hat, aus welchen Gründen und wer deine Daten auch weitergegeben hat. Das fällt dir manchmal auf die Füße ganz subtil und das wird in einer Informationsgesellschaft, in der irgendwann mal niemand mehr nicht im Netz unterwegs ist, wird das einfach dann jeden betreffen. Und da muss man schon mal vorsorglich auf dieses Problem hinweisen, was dann eigentlich jetzt schon uns als Netzbürger, die wir damit groß geworden sind, aber dann irgendwann in knapper absehbarer Zeit wirklich jeden betrifft. Dieses Problem muss man einfach ansprechen und dann vielleicht jetzt schon Regularien schaffen, dass es dann, wenn es wirklich schlimm wird, dass wir das dann dagegen regeln können.
Gut, aber ich hab ja auch da die Möglichkeit, also gerade wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel auf einen Vertrag abschließe, dann will ich ja ein, dass zum Beispiel eine Schufa-Auskunft eingeholt wird. Dann weiß ich ja, von wo die Daten kommen und auch bei der Schufa kann ich ja eine Selbstauskunft machen. Also auch da habe ich eigentlich wieder die Möglichkeit zu erfahren, woher kommen meine Scoring-Punkte oder welche Scoring-Punkte habe ich dort. Also auch da sehe ich jetzt eigentlich nicht wieder den Vorteil durch den Datenbrief. Was ich aber übrigens nebenbei, ich habe eigentlich meine Punkte soweit ja auch schon erwähnt, aber ansonsten finde ich eigentlich noch einen ganz interessanten Punkt oder eine interessante Frage. Was ist eigentlich mit den ganzen Daten, die so in den digitalen Netzen anfallen, die so im Internet anfallen? Da gibt es ja unheimlich viele Daten, die jetzt nicht unbedingt personenbezogen sind oder die zumindest anonymisiert sind. Also ich sage mal, die ganzen Logfiles, die ich habe von Website-Besuchen und so weiter, wo vielleicht es nur eine IP ist oder wo ich aber zum Beispiel weiß, es ist ein Kunde, es ist eine Person, aber ich weiß nicht, welches es ist, sozusagen, den Fall gibt es ja auch. Also es gibt ja sehr viele, sage ich mal, sehr viele Datensammlungen im Internet, die nicht mehr so funktionieren, wie man das früher gehabt hat, wenn man irgendwie bei einem Versandhaus bestellt, und man weiß ganz klar, okay, da ist ein Kunde und der hat das und das bestellt und das sind jetzt die Daten über ihn, sondern wo ich halt Daten habe, die irgendwie Auswertungen sind von meinem Surfverhalten und so weiter, wo ich im Grunde genommen gigantische Datenmengen habe, die permanent anfallen, wenn man sich Google anguckt oder überhaupt Websites, Webportale, wo einfach riesige Datenmengen anfallen, wie gesagt, die noch nicht mal unbedingt so personalisiert sein müssen, aber die natürlich trotzdem sozusagen einem Benutzerkonto zugeschrieben können, beispielsweise wenn ich das über Cookies mache oder Ähnliches. Und da gibt's, sag ich mal, da ist es ja dann nicht mehr so einfach, wie, sag ich mal, wie so ein Datenbrief vielleicht noch vor 20 Jahren funktioniert hätte, wenn das einfach so Sachen sind, wo ich angerufen hab, was bestellt hab oder Ähnliches oder nicht, da hat das ja sehr viele Spuren. Deswegen frag ich mich so ein bisschen, was nennt ihr dann Daten oder was müsste dann da alles mit drin sein und wie, wie, wie wendet man das eigentlich auf alles an, was so im Internet anfällt?
Also diese Daten, die du jetzt meintest, sind sogenannte personenbeziehbare Daten, also keine, das ist so eine kleine, feine Unterscheidung, also personenbezogene Daten oder Personendaten, wo ich jetzt wirklich weiß, das ist Frank-Rosengard, so und so Straße, oder personenbeziehbare, das heißt so Daten, die ich halt möglicherweise indirekt jemanden zuordnen kann. Es können anonyme Daten sein, es können pseudonyme Daten sein, das heißt also, ich selbst kann die Ordnung zwar nicht machen, bei einer IP-Adresse zum Beispiel, aber zum Beispiel eine Polizei, die einerseits bei mir das Log-File beschlagnahmt, und andererseits zum Provider geht und sagt mal, wer war denn das, wer war denn mit der IP zu der Uhrzeit, zu der Sekunde unterwegs, die können diese pseudonyme Siedlung natürlich wieder aufheben. Da muss ich sagen, da haben wir kein Rezept für. So, das ist einfach, da gibt es keinen Datenbrief, weil wir natürlich sagen, diese Daten dürfen natürlich nicht mehr Daten erhoben werden, als sie jetzt schon da sind, nur um den Datenbrief zuzustellen. Was durchaus denkbar ist, wenn es so Daten gibt, dass wenn man jetzt bei deinem Online-Dienst eingeloggt ist, dass diese Daten dann auch irgendwie transparent gemacht werden, dass sie da sind. Wobei, also Lockfile sollten ja eigentlich nach einer Woche oder nach 24 Stunden gelöscht sein, die würden dann auch gar nicht in diese Datenbrief-Regelung reinfallen. Spannende Sache ist noch, ganz kurz, Spannende Sache ist noch bei so dynamischen Daten. Das bedeutet Daten, die zu Echtzeit oder zu bestimmten Zeitpunkten berechnet werden. Also gerade das sind so Scoring-Werte, wo dann entschieden wird, ob ich bei einer Bestellung auf Rechnung bezahlen darf oder ob meine Kreditkarte jetzt irgendwie, ob die Transaktion vielleicht komisch ist, ob ich da vielleicht noch eine besondere Sicherheitsabfrage brauche oder nicht. Die sind auch noch interessanter, weil die wollen wir natürlich eigentlich auch greifbar machen. Das heißt, da müssen wir dann vielleicht mit einer allgemeinen Beschreibung reingehen, mit einer allgemeinen Verständigung. Wir haben diesen Datenverarbeitungsvorgang. Es gibt den Fall, da gibt es eine Anfrage nach einem Score-Wert. Und diesen Score-Wert berechnen wir aus den Faktoren A, B, C und D. Da sind natürlich dann auch wieder Geschäftsgeheimnisse betroffen von den Firmen. Aber irgendwie müssen wir versuchen, das greifbar zu machen. Ich denke, das sind so Details, da müssen wir einfach sehen. Das sehen wir jetzt auch nicht als statisch, so muss das sein. Sondern da suchen wir natürlich auch Input und der Datenbrief kann sich da auch weiter entwickeln. Also wenn wir sagen, okay der Datenbrief ist schon super, aber diese Scoring-Geschichten haben wir irgendwie noch nicht erfasst und die werden jetzt in der Wirtschaft immer wichtiger, dann müssen wir da einfach nachbessern, ganz klar. Aber da haben wir jetzt so noch kein Patentrezept, was diese wirklich flüssigen Daten oder in Bewegung befindlichen Daten angeht, die jetzt keiner konkreten Personen zuzuordnen sind. Ich guck mal zu Erdgeist drüber. Patentrezept wüsste ich jetzt nicht, also müssen wir halt sagen, okay die erfassen wir halt nicht und da wünschen wir uns aber auch, dass sie möglichst kurzfristig nur sind oder nur temporär sind.
Aber das finde ich ja zum Teil auch, also was mich eben auch sehr interessieren würde, ist eben auch bezogen auf Daten, die dann auch speziell ein Nutzer zugeordnet werden können. Also beispielsweise, ich habe meinen Google-Account, ich google irgendwelche Begriffe bei Google, ich habe vielleicht Google-Mail, ich habe da meine Kontakte drin. Ich sag mal, wenn Google mir alles ausdrucken würde, was sie irgendwie über mich haben, dann schicken sie mir wahrscheinlich 200 Seiten oder sowas.
Google hat am allgemeinen ja deine Zuhauseadresse nicht und die Idee ist auch, dass du kontaktiert wirst, über die Art und Weise, wie du normalerweise mit diesem Dienst in Kontakt trittst. Dass dir dann einfach mal auf der Webseite unten ein prominenter Link hingepackt wird, klick mal da drauf, wir wissen Dinge über dich, wenn du wissen willst, welche das sind. Dann klick da drauf und dann kann man in diesem Interface darauf hinweisen, wie sich der Kunde dort die Informationen besorgen kann und wie er sie löschen kann und wie er, natürlich, was auch spannend ist, wie er vielleicht seinen Account ganze entfernen kann.
Gut, aber das heißt wirklich, man müsste gerne alle Informationen löschen, die irgendwie in diesem ganzen Prozess angefallen sind. Also sind das jetzt, das seien jetzt irgendwelche Google Docs, das seien irgendwelche Kontakte, Twitter, müsste man irgendwie sämtliche Tweets schicken.
Nein, gerade nicht. Also du müsstest die Möglichkeit haben, dir die wieder abzurufen oder machen, dass sie die löschen. Aber ansonsten müssen sie dich nur darauf hinweisen, dass diese Informationen existieren. Es ist nicht der Fall, dass im Datenbrief alle Daten drin stehen sollen.
Also auch zum Beispiel beim Kontoauszug ist natürlich Quatsch, wenn du sozusagen am Ende des Jahres noch mal einen gebündelten Kontoauszug bekommst. Übrigens, das war eine Kontobewegung, sondern die kommen ja auch immer ständig. Also müssen ja auch keine neuen Informationen dazu getan werden. Es geht auch wirklich nicht darum, einfach per se irgendwie erst mal so ein riesen Datenberg zu erzeugen, sondern es geht einfach darum, auf beiden Seiten ein Bewusstsein dafür zu schaffen, welche Kategorien von Daten sind da, welche Qualität haben diese Daten, welchen zahlenmäßigen Umfang möglicherweise, ohne dass sie jetzt einzelne aufgeschlüsselt sind, und dass es auf beiden Seiten auch ein Nachdenken gibt, ob diese Daten wirklich notwendig sind, einerseits überhaupt zu haben, andererseits, ob sie langen gespeichert werden müssen.
Wie du eingangs erwähntest, wenn du wirklich mehrere hundert Datenbriefe pro Jahr bekämen, dann hast du eh noch ganz andere Probleme, aber dann hast du zumindest die Option, dass in fünf Jahren es vielleicht so aussieht, dass mit deiner normalen Post, mit den Firmen, mit denen du Kontakt haben möchtest, dass die dir noch kurz hinten ranheften, das sind die Informationen, die wir dir gespeichert haben und alle anderen sich schon gar nicht mehr trauen, Informationen über dich zu speichern, sondern eh dafür gesorgt haben, dass du da nicht mehr auftauchst. Sodass dann diese mehrere hundert Datenbriefe sich dann einfach mal innerhalb von kurzer Zeit komplett erledigt haben.
Gut, also glaube ich eigentlich nicht. Mir ist es eigentlich in den meisten Fällen eben auch ganz lieb, wenn man mich wiedererkennt, wenn ich irgendwo anrufe zum Beispiel, oder wenn man halt dann weiß, worauf man zugreifen muss. Aber gut, das ist natürlich eine persönliche Einschätzungssache, wo ich aber so ein bisschen kritisch finde, dass man dann sagt, wir wollen das eben verbindlich, zwangsweise für die ganze Bevölkerung haben. Sondern da fände ich es dann schon immer noch wesentlich besser, als wäre wirklich dann ein Opt-in in den Datenbrief, dass ich sage, ich möchte den haben, ich will diese Information haben, dass ich die dann kriege. Klar, ich weiß natürlich so nicht, welche Firma ich dann überhaupt kontaktieren muss, das ist richtig, aber ehrlich gesagt halte ich sozusagen die Belästigung der gesamten Bevölkerung mit diesen ganzen Briefen, die ich kriege, einfach für völlig unverhältnismäßig und auch die Kosten, die da entstehen, wenn ich eben gerade wie gesagt an kleine Firmen denke, an irgendwelche kleinen Service-Dienste, an irgendwelche Pizza-Lieferdienste und so weiter. Die einfach nicht darauf ausgerichtet sind.
Das hatten wir aber schon, nee, kein Moment, das hatten wir jetzt schon, sagen, mehrfach und die Idee ist einfach sozusagen, auch die kleine Firma, also gerade der Pizza-Lieferdienst schickt er ja jeden Monat den neuen Bestellzettel mit den aktuellen Preisen, da kann er auch einfach hinten dran schreiben. Das ist zumindest das, was mir gesagt wurde, als ich das vor einer Viertelstunde nachgefragt habe.
Also von daher... Also nicht jeder belästigt mich mit Werbung, und es ist natürlich vielleicht eine Motivation, genau das dann zu tun. Also mich eben mit Werbung zu belästigen, wo man mir eh schon diesen Brief schicken muss, dann kann man eben auch nochmal Werbung schicken. Und ob das erwünscht ist, weiß ich nicht.
Die Frage, also ich sage, es gibt, man könnte die Firmen unterteilen, es gibt Firmen, die sind sowieso mit dir im Kontakt, da wär es also kein Problem. Die heften einfach irgendwo hinten dran.
Richtig?
Okay, dann gibt es Firmen, die sind nicht mit dir im Kontakt. Die müssten dir die Daten einmal schicken, dann wirst du von denen auch nichts mehr hören, solange sich da nichts ändert.
Auch richtig.
Aber vielleicht habe ich das falsch verstanden, aber soll das nicht die jährliche Sache sein?
Ja, wir wollen eigentlich schon eine jährliche, wobei ich mir auch vorstellen könnte, dass man sagen kann, okay nach einem zweiten Brief, dann noch alle zwei Jahre oder sowas, wenn es diese Daten wirklich gibt.
Es geht auch um diese aktive und passive Datenhaltung. Das heißt, wenn meine Daten bei der Firma liegen, die Firma mit den Daten aber nichts mehr macht, also sozusagen keinen Kontakt mehr zu mir herstellt, dann muss sie mir auch keinen Datenbrief mehr schreiben.
Also wenn sie die Rechnung für die Pizza abheftet, dann brauchst du nicht mehr schreiben. Aber wenn sie natürlich nach wie vor in einer Datenbank ist, damit sie dich zurückrufen können, wenn noch Fragen sind oder sowas, dann sind es natürlich schon noch aktive Daten und dann müssen sie auch informieren.
Und da war die Trennung, ist glaube ich schwierig. Denn wenn ich am Pizza-Dienst anrufe, ist das der erste, was sie normalerweise machen. Sie fragen mich dann mal eine Telefonnummer und sie gucken nach, ob ich da schon drin stehe. Und wenn die Telefonnummer da schon drin steht, dann wissen sie, wo ich wohne und können mir die Pizza liefern. Ist das jetzt aktiver Datenbestand? Ja, und das ist aber natürlich auch in meinem Interesse. Ich will ja nicht jedes Mal meine Adresse durchgeben. Also, naja gut, ich finde das halt...
Bei wenigen Pizza-Lieferereien bist du da Kunde und wie oft bringen die dir was nach Hause und wie hoch ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass sie dir dann wirklich da hinten noch kurz bei einer Lieferung deinen Datenbrief hintenrand tackert oder bei der aktuellen Preisliste, die sie dir eh zuschicken? Also das macht einfach da nicht viel mehr Aufwand. Gerade im Fall der kleineren Firma, eine kleinere Firma, die mit dir nicht im Kontakt bleibt, hat einfach auch wenig Grund, über dich Daten zu speichern. Dann bist du halt nicht deren Kunde. Wenn sie irgendwie ein Jahr mit dir keine Transaktion hatten, dann bist du kein wirklicher aktiver Kunde mehr von denen. Und dann müssen sie die Daten auch nicht für Fremde zum Abgriff bereit da haben oder förmlich was sie völlig zum Verlieren einlädt.
Gut, also ich mach selber IT-Supporten. Wenn ich sehe, was so für IT am Start ist, bei vielen kleinen Unternehmen, dann ist das eben nicht so, dass die mal eben schnell so was umstehen können, sondern das ist einfach mit einem Riesenaufwand verbunden.
Okay Tim, aber ganz kurz, es ist ein Halt, alle.
Mund halten. Kann ja wohl nicht wahr sein. Tim, ich würde dich bitten, jetzt mal kurz dran zu bleiben und einfach weiter zuzuhören und möglicherweise noch was zu sagen, weil wir jetzt mit Adam sprechen und Adam, findet die die Klasse, arbeitet aber auch im EDV-Bereich. Hallo, guten Abend.
Hallo, zusammen grüße euch. Ja, ein paar Punkte, die ich während der ganzen Gespräche wahrscheinlich kurz ansprechen will. Ich fang gleich mal mit der ersten Sache an. Ich finde den Ansatz eigentlich recht gut, dass man das Ganze proaktiv macht. Aber wie ihr schon erwähnt hattet, ich weiß gar nicht, wen ich jetzt fragen müsste, ob er meine Daten hat. Ja, ich will das vielleicht mal vergleichen mit ich hab meine Wohnung, ich hab einen Schlüssel. Ich weiß, dass man ein Vermieter Schlüssel hat. Aber ich wüsste jetzt nicht, wen ich noch fragen müsste von den Formeltern, wer vielleicht jetzt mein Haus Schlüssel noch hat. Wenn ich jetzt die mir sage, okay, wir haben ihn, dann weiß ich das halt. Und es ist so, dass man mit Sicherheit initial so was mal raus schicken könnte. Und dann auch vielleicht den Kunden sagt, okay, den Datenbrief, ob egal ob man das jetzt Pflicht macht, zur Pflicht macht oder nicht, dass man sagt, okay, wenn sie nicht zustimmen, dann würden wir den Datenbrief jetzt nächstes Jahr oder die nächsten Jahre nicht mehr zuschicken. Da gibt es eine Sicherheit Partner, wo ich mir sicher bin, die auch regelmäßig mit mir in Kontakt stehen, dass ich von denen Datenbrief nicht brauche. Aber was ich ein bisschen gezielter ansprechen will, sind gerade diese Datenhaltungsgesellschaften, mit denen ich teilweise beruflich auch zu tun gehabt habe. Die sammeln Daten, verkaufen die, machen Profile, wo dann halt Marketingagenturen, wie auch immer, Zielgruppen, spezifische Profile da anlegen. Und letztendlich, ja, schwer zu sagen, werden die Daten von den Unternehmen gekauft. Die machen damit Werbung, weil so ein Brief, da irgendwas rauszusticken zu einem Kunden, kostet nicht viel Geld. Aber wenn man die Datenhaltung halt sehr teuer macht, mit diesen Datenbrief, dann werden die Unternehmen sich ganz genau überlegen, was für Daten sie noch im System haben. Es ist ja jetzt schon teilweise so, dass große Marketing-Aktionen gemacht werden. Da werden jede Menge Daten nicht mitselektiert, obwohl diese Daten mit im System sind. Und von daher finde ich das einen sehr guten Ansatz. Und auch dieses Argument, was ihr vorhin gebracht habt, dass es ja eigentlich auch für Vorteile von Unternehmen ist. Ja, im Ansicht der Kundenbindung. Wenn ich meinen Kunden sage, hey, pass auf, ich habe diese Daten von mir im System, würde ich als Kunde klasse finden. Und die Kunden, die es halt nicht wollen, die können es halt einfach wegschmeißen, ja. Aber ich denke mal, das Bewusstsein ist bei den Leuten noch gar nicht da. Vorhin hatte ich immer das Argument gehört, viele interessiert es gar nicht, was mit ihren Daten passiert. Weil ihnen gar nicht bewusst ist, was mit diesen Daten gemacht wird. Und welche Wege diese ganzen Daten gehen. Und auch diese Kontrolle, die er nochmal angesprochen hat. Ich glaube, ein Bestandteil des Datenbriefs ist ja auch, dass dort drin steht, woher die Daten gekommen sind. Ob das jetzt mal eine Bestellung von mir gewesen ist oder ob die Daten irgendwo eingekauft worden sind. Das heißt, wenn ich so einen Datenbrief bekommen würde, sehen, wo haben die denn die Daten herbekommen, dann könnte ich da aktiv rangehen und mich informieren, wie denn die andere Firma, von der die Daten bekommen haben, an meine Daten angekommen ist. Grundsätzlich finde ich das eine gute Sache. Mit Sicherheit muss man da noch ein bisschen rumfallen an einigen Ecken. Aber der Ansatz, das proaktiv zu machen, finde ich einfach klasse.
So, da haben wir jetzt endlich auch einen Befürworter. Das hat ja lange genug gedauert.
Ja klar, mit Sicherheit gibt es immer Feinheiten und dann passt die andere Sache nicht und die andere. Aber ich meine, wie oft sind irgendwelche Gesetze auf den Weg gebracht worden und sind nach einem oder zwei Jahren angepasst worden.
Und du hast aber selber auch damit gearbeitet und würdest trotzdem sozusagen das Konzept befürworten?
Auf jeden Fall, auf jeden Fall.
Ich würde ganz gerne kurz den Tim, ne? Wie ist es bei Behörden? Also wir haben jetzt viel über Firmen gesprochen, aber würdest du denn prinzipiell bei Behörden befürworten?
Bei Behörden würde ich es ganz klar, also sag ich mal, würde ich auf jeden Fall befürworten, zum einen, erst mal wesentlich kritischer zu sein mit dem Datenschutz. Und zwar einfach deshalb, weil ich da keine Wahl habe. Wenn ich einem Unternehmen Daten von mir gebe, oder ich sag mal, wenn ein Unternehmen Daten von mir hat, dann ist es meistens so, dass entweder ich dem Unternehmen diese Daten gegeben habe oder aber an anderen Unternehmen, die Daten verkauft haben, wo ich das aber meistens auch erlaubt habe. Das heißt, ich sollte vielleicht eigentlich, und es wäre eigentlich wünschenswert, wenn Menschen sich genauer angucken, was erlaube ich eigentlich demjenigen, dem ich meine Daten gebe? Und will ich dem vielleicht nicht erlauben, diese Daten weiterzugeben? Und soll ich da vielleicht darauf achten, was der in seinem AGB schreibt oder was der dazuschreibt und ob ich dem vielleicht widersprechen möchte? Das heißt hier, wenn ich das sozusagen, ich sehe da eigentlich eine ganz klare Trennung zwischen der privaten Wirtschaft und Behörden. Denn bei der privaten Wirtschaft, das ist in aller Regel so, dass ich eben, wie gesagt, entweder die Daten erst herausgegeben habe oder aber zumindest eingewilligt habe, dass sie weitergegeben werden können. Ansonsten wird halt ein Vertragsbruch begangen. Das heißt also, weil ich sehe halt auch, dass es eigentlich auch noch ein Punkt, den ich zu dem Datenbrief einfach sehe, ist, dass ich es ein bisschen unverhältnismäßig finde, dass man sozusagen der Privatwirtschaft diese Last aufwirkt quasi oder das von Unternehmen verlangt, wo ich eigentlich viel kritischer finde, welche Informationen der Staat eigentlich alles über einen speichert, wo man eben keine Möglichkeit hat, dem zu widersprechen oder dagegen vorzugehen, sondern wo es einfach gesetzt ist und wo man sich dagegen auch nicht wehren kann. Insofern, ich sag mal, mein Interesse jetzt zu wissen, was die über mich speichern, wäre ehrlich gesagt nicht besonders groß. Da finde ich es allerdings wirklich sinnvoll, wenn es da ein Opt-in gäbe, wenn ich zumindest das Recht habe, dass ich da immer sagen kann, ok, ich will diesen Datenbrief haben und ich will das auch regelmäßig wissen, wobei mir im Grunde genommen auch glaube ich da ein Auskunftrecht völlig reicht, wenn ich das auf Nachfrage erfahren kann, wobei ich da natürlich auch nicht über den Überblick habe, welche Behörden gibt das alles. Da finde ich es eigentlich schon sinnvoll, ich würde da informiert werden, das finde ich schon eher interessant, wobei ich da auch sinnvoller finde, das als Opt-in zu machen, also wenn das jeder bekommt, weil ich da auch einfach wieder einen gigantischen Aufwand sehe für viele Menschen, die es einfach nicht interessiert und wo ich denke, da wird einfach dann auch Geld verschwendet. Aber wie gesagt, dieser Punkt Privatwirtschaft kontra Staat finde ich einfach, dass man da wesentlich mehr auch an der ganzen Datenschutzdiskussion eigentlich auf den Staat fokussieren sollte, denn der speichert Daten ohne, dass man diese Daten explizit gibt und ohne, dass man dem einwilligt und ohne, dass man da jetzt vielleicht einen persönlichen Zweck drin sieht, wie wenn ich vielleicht einen Google-Account habe und halt auch was im Sinne derin sehe, dass Google meine Daten hat sozusagen und die vielleicht auch verknüpft und ich das vielleicht auch sinnvoll finde, kann ich ja selbst entscheiden.
Wenn du das bewusst tust, dann ist das dann eine Sache, das ist schön.
Aber wenn dir das anspricht... Im Staat habe ich eben nicht die Möglichkeit, das dagegen vorzugehen. Deswegen finde ich stahliche Daten sammeln auch wesentlich kritischer als private.
Wir hatten vorhin bei der Vorlesung auch schon die lustige Idee, auf deinem Kontoauszug deiner Bank sämtliche Anfragen des BaFin, der Steuerpolizei dort mit einzutragen, sodass du Bescheid weißt, wann der Staat auch private Daten ohne dein Wissen eingesammelt hat.
Finde ich sehr spannend.
Eine Verständnisfrage, der Datenbrief soll doch für alle gelten. Der Datenbrief soll für alle gelten. Also grundsätzlich geht es schon um sowohl staatliche Stellen als auch privat.
Genau.
Richtig.
Tim, du sagst, von staatlichen Stellen würdest du das gerne wissen, aber von den Privatfirmen nicht.
Es geht ja hier um eine gerätliche Verpflichtung, die ich auferlege, Firmen, dass sie das raus schicken, und zwar ohne, dass es jemand ausdrücklich wünscht. Und die finde ich einfach völlig unverhältnismäßig und glaube eben, dass sie mehr Kollateralschäden verursacht, als dass sie irgendjemanden nützt. Wie gesagt...
Das heißt aber, du sagst, das große Ziel irgendwie möglicherweise ändert sich, das Datenschutzbewusstsein in der Privatwirtschaft ist für dich dann aber auch nicht verfolgungswert, beziehungsweise nicht verfolgungswert genug.
Ja, beziehungsweise ich sehe mich einfach nicht in der Position, anderen Menschen das vorzuschreiben, die sie meiner Meinung nach mit ihren Daten umgehen sollen. Also ich meine, das ist eine Philosophie, dass man sagt, Daten sollte man irgendwo, seine persönlichen Daten sollte man in den Griff behalten, da sollte man die Kontrolle drüber haben. Es ist sehr strebenswert dafür zu sorgen, dass möglichst wenige Leute diese Daten haben. Das ist eine Philosophie, die finde ich auch legitim. Die soll doch jeder so fahren, der das gerne möchte. Aber da jetzt sozusagen, weil wir denken oder weil bestimmte Leute denken, das ist so der richtige Weg und deswegen müssen wir im Grunde genommen die ganze Bevölkerung dazu erziehen, finde ich eigentlich so falsch.
Wir sehen das wirklich auch eher andersrum, dass wir nicht die Bevölkerung erziehen, sondern dass wir einfach mit der Drohung, also diese Datenschutzanfragen sind halt irgendwie auch teuer in der Bearbeitung, dass einfach nur die Drohung, dass plötzlich die gesamte Bevölkerung ankommen könnte und die Informationen dann wirklich abfragen und dann wie da dann erst die Kosten verursachen, wird dann schon retroaktiv erst machen, dass die Firmen diese Daten so schnell wie möglich loswerden wollen, wenn sie sie nicht wirklich brauchen.
Sie kann ja jederzeit fragen, wenn sie...
Na gut, aber das sei es, wo sie fragen sollen.
Tim, hast du das mal versucht?
Ich hab's noch nicht versucht.
Mach das mal bitte.
Wir haben nämlich mal hier als Projekt, da haben wir von einer Kollegin uns sind wir hergegangen, haben gesagt, so, wir versuchen jetzt mal einfach mit diesem Auskunftsgesetz rauszufinden, was so geht. Was passiert ist folgendes, du kriegst von den meisten Privatfirmen nur eine sehr schleppende Antwort. Wir haben dieses Projekt innerhalb einer Woche gemacht und wir haben von den Privatfirmen die Antwort nur deshalb so schnell bekommen, weil wir immer gesagt haben, so hört mal zu, wir sind ein Radio-Sender, wir machen gerade ein Projekt über Datenauskunft, könnt ihr das vielleicht mal ein bisschen schneller machen. Und dann ist es auch so, die geben dir sozusagen, die geben dir dann Daten, aber das sind nicht wirklich viele. Das sind insbesondere nicht alle, die du eigentlich wissen willst.
Das heißt, dieses Recht ist sehr theoretisch.
Gut, aber das sind jetzt Einzelheiten dieser Möglichkeit, die Daten abzufragen und hier kann man natürlich überlegen, ob man da was verbessern will. Also wenn man sagt, da reichen vielleicht, ich weiß nicht, ob inwiefern es da irgendwelche Sanktionen gibt, da kann man natürlich sagen, okay, vielleicht reichen diese Sanktionen nicht aus, vielleicht brauche ich bessere Möglichkeiten, wenn mir diese Daten nicht gegeben werden, auch dagegen vorzugehen. Aber das ist natürlich dann was anderes, als wenn ich von einem Datenbrief rede.
Okay, das heißt aber sozusagen, du, wir hatten das schon am, der erste Anrufer, da war das so ähnlich, du wärst im Prinzip für so eine Art Datenbrief per Opt-in. Also quasi jeder Bürger hat sehr einfach und zu jeder Zeit die Möglichkeit, sofort zu sagen, so Firma, bitte jetzt raus mit den Daten und zwar alle.
Das finde ich schon eine sinnvolle Sache, also dass ich die Daten abfragen kann, ja, dass ich regelmäßig, dass die Firmen verpflichtet werden, mir regelmäßig was zuzuschicken, halte ich nicht für sinnvoll.
Okay, dann haben wir noch sozusagen, also das ist ein Punkt, den werden wir heute nicht klären, weil da bist du halt einfach andere Ansicht. Der einzige Punkt, der mich noch interessieren würde, ist, was der Datenbrief ja auch noch klärt, ist, dass du erfährst, welche Firmen Daten von dir haben, von denen du das gar nicht weißt. Würdest du das dann einfach unter den Tisch fallen lassen, oder hast du auch noch einen Lösungsvorschlag?
Das würde ich im Prinzip unter den Tisch fallen lassen, einfach deshalb, weil die Firmen in aller Regel, solange sie nicht gegen das Gesetz verstoßen, und das ist natürlich immer eine Sache, die irgendwie verfolgenswert ist, aber solange sie nicht gegen das Gesetz verstoßen, werden sie diese Daten nur haben, wenn ich dem auch entsprechend zugestimmt habe. Und wenn ich der Meinung bin, dass ich das sehr kritisch sehe, dass ich nicht möchte, dass meine Daten irgendwie unkontrolliert verbreitet werden, dann muss ich halt aufpassen, wem ich was erlaube. Und da denke ich, in dem Punkt sollte man eigentlich dann die Eigenverantwortung den einzelnen Menschen überlassen. Wem erlauben sie das, wem es wichtig ist, dass es nicht geschieht, der soll aufpassen, wem er seine Daten gibt. Und was er diesen Menschen erlaubt, oder diesen Firmen, oder diesen Organisationen. Aber ich würde nicht sagen, dass man deswegen Firmenverpflichten sollte, jedem diese Briefe herauszuschicken.
Du bist der Ansicht zu sagen, letztendlich hat jeder die totale Kontrolle darüber, wem er seine Daten gibt.
Das sollte jeder selbst entscheiden, ja genau.
Nee, nee, das ist nicht die Frage. Die Frage ist, du glaubst, wenn ich genug aufpasse, dann habe ich wirklich die totale Kontrolle darüber, wer meine Daten bekommt oder nicht.
Es gibt natürlich Unternehmen, die gegen das Gesetz verstoßen. Klar, und Gesetzesverstöße werden ja mehr oder weniger verfolgt. Also das gibt es überall.
Da hilft doch der Datenbrief nicht dagegen, das ist richtig.
Ja genau, also ich kann auch ein Mord begehen, das ist auch verboten. Wie gesagt, Gesetzesverstöße sind immer möglich, aber sozusagen, solange man die mal ausschießt, dann werde ich in aller Regel auch selbst mehr oder weniger vielleicht durch meine Unaufmerksamkeit auch dafür gesorgt haben, dass es passiert ist. Aber wenn es mir eben wichtig ist, dann muss ich eben aufmerksam sein, denke ich, was ich unterschreibe.
Sagt Tim, der sagt nämlich irgendwie, die Gesetze jetzt, die wir jetzt haben, reichen schon. Datenbrief, der Pflichtweise an alle rausgeschickt wird, das brauchen wir nicht. Und man soll halt einfach selber mal ein bisschen besser aufpassen. Wir reden gleich noch eine halbe Stunde über den Datenbrief und ob der sinnvoll ist oder nicht. Bevor wir das weitermachen, machen wir aber Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr.
Sie sind jung und sprechen eine uns nicht unbekannte Sprache. Und was Sie zu sagen haben. Singen Sie! Ein Konzerthighlight in Deutsch. Alle live an einem Abend. Wir nennen sie einfach Neue Deutschpoeten live. Samstag, 12. Juni, im Astrakulturhaus Berlin. So lange es noch Karten gibt, gibt es Karten überall wo es Karten gibt. Natürlich auch auf FrippD. Neue Ideen, neue Texte, neue Musik. Neue Deutschpoeten live.
Präsentiert von Fripp.
Um kurze halb 12.
Nachrichten.
Mit Kaietan Dürlich.
Griechenland braucht, wie es aussieht, noch mehr Geld. Bundeswirtschaftsminister Brüderle sprach am Nachmittag von 135 Milliarden Euro für die nächsten drei Jahre. Bisher war von 45 Milliarden die Rede. Auch Deutschland muss offenbar mehr Geld für Griechenland zur Verfügung stellen als geplant. Nicht 8, sondern mindestens 25 Milliarden Euro soll der deutsche Anteil betragen. Die Opposition im Bundestag hat den Berufsbildungsbericht der Bundesregierung kritisiert. Die Grünen sagen, die Regierung müsse endlich die Ursachen der Bildungsmisere angehen und bessere Bildungseinrichtungen schaffen. Im aktuellen Berufsbildungsbericht steht, dass jährlich bis zu 80.000 Jugendliche die Schule ohne Abschluss verlassen. Bildungsministerin Schawan will deshalb vor allem Hauptschülern mit Lernproblembetreuer zur Seite stellen. Im Kampf gegen die Ölpest im Golf von Mexiko haben Experten damit begonnen, den Ölteppich in Brand zu stecken. Damit soll verhindert werden, dass sich das Öl weiter ausbreitet. Auch heute klappte es nicht, die Lecks an der gesunkenen Bohrinsel zu schließen. Täglich strömen aus ihnen zigtausende Liter Öl ins Meer. Der Ölteppich ist noch etwa 30 Kilometer von der amerikanischen Südküste entfernt. Bayern München spielt im Champions League Finale gegen Inter Mailand. Im Rückspiel heute Abend konnte das Team aus Barcelona den Hinspielrückstand nicht mehr aufholen, auch wenn die Partie 1 zu 0 für Barcelona endete. Die Partie gegen Bayern München findet am 22. Mai in Madrid statt. Aber Berlin hat sich in der Basketball-Bundesliga auf den dritten Tabellenplatz verbessert. Das Team besiegt am Abend Bremerhaven nach einem harten Knampfkampf ganz knapp mit 74 zu 73. Es bleibt sterlin klar und trocken heute Nacht. Die Temperaturen liegen dann zwischen 5 bis 9 Grad. Hier sind die aktuellen Werte. In Cottbus da sind es auch schon 9 Grad. Neuropin 11, Angermünde 13, Potsdam und Frankfurt 14, Wittenberge 15. Berlin sehr wechselhaft zwischen 10 bis 15 Grad. Morgen wird es dann wieder richtig schön werden. Es kommt die Sonne raus. Dazu gibt es warme 23 bis 620 Grad. Zum Wochenende hin gibt es dann allerdings wieder ein bisschen mehr Wolken und es wird dann auch wieder deutlich kühler werden. A20 Rostock Richtung Colts-Uckermark. Zwischen Prenzlau-Süd und dem Colts-Uckermark da liegen Reifenteile auf der Fahrbahn rum. Da ist auch die linke Spur blockiert. Bitte sehr vorsichtig fahren. Auf der A24 wenden Richtung Hamburg. Zwischen Raschtitte-Weißleben-Ost und Herzsprung ist immer noch die linke Spur wegen Bauarbeiten gesperrt. Und im Regionalverkehr gibt es eine Störung. Da ist die Linie RE1 zwischen Fangschleuse und Fürstenwalde unterbrochen. Da fahren Busse als Ersatz. Euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBW.
Und wenn im Radio 101, 5, dann Fritz in Frankfurt Oder.
Heute Chaos Radio mit den Herren Erbgeist.
Naja, dessen Mikrofon ich aufmachen sollte.
Hallo.
Die ganze Zeit geschimpft, dass sie nicht rechtzeitig hingehen und dann so was. Und dem Herrn Rosengard, der jetzt aber tatsächlich einfach mal nicht am Mikrofon ist, aber trotzdem da. Und mir ist Markus Richter und wir sprechen heute über den Datenbrief. Das ist so eine Idee, die hatte der Chaos Computer Club, dessen Sendung, das ja quasi ist, jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Und wo es darum geht, dass Firmen euch einmal im Jahr zustellen sollen, mit welchen Daten von euch sie gerade arbeiten. Das gibt für und wieder die Hörer, die in der Sendung bis jetzt angerufen haben, sind eher dagegen, weil sie meinen, naja, die Leute werden halt von diesem Datenbrief irgendwie belästigt. Aber jetzt interessiert das doch keinen und erinnert sowieso nichts. Und überhaupt, im Chat zur Sendung wurde gerade noch gesagt, ja, ihr habt folgende Frage noch gar nicht beantwortet. Und da muss ich mal zusagen, liebe Leute, es ist das Chaos Radio. Wir lesen auch nebenher den Chat und Twitter und überhaupt wo ihr noch unterwegs seid. Aber wenn ihr wirklich sicher gehen wollt, wenn ihr wirklich wirklich ganz sicher gehen wollt, dass eine Frage, die ihr habt beantwortet ist, dann hilft wirklich nur eins. Weil ich sag's ganz ehrlich, wenn wir hier irgendwie netzpolitische Themen diskutieren, noch so einen Chat nachzuverfolgen, der vorbeirauscht, ist doch ein bisschen schwieriger. Adam hat es zum Beispiel richtig gemacht, er hat angerufen, wir haben vorhin schon eine Weile gesprochen. Adam wollte uns jetzt gerade noch was zum Datenbrief und seinen Umgang damit erzählen.
Ja, ich wollte mal ganz kurz eine kleine Anekdote erzählen. Ich habe mal in der Tat die Möglichkeit gehabt, bei einem Datensammler einen Datensatz von mir zu finden. Vielleicht ist es im Einzelnen gar nicht so gefährlich, wenn einzelne Unternehmen Daten von mir haben in Bezug auf irgendwelche vorangegangenen Geschäfte und so weiter. Aber das gefährliche daran ist, wenn die Daten verknüpft werden und in Bezug auf diese Verknüpfung dann irgendwelche Rückschlüsse gezogen werden. Und ich hab das mal vor zwei Jahren gesehen, und Daten war zu mir. Und da ist mir ehrlich gesagt schlecht geworden, was da teilweise an Daten von mir drin gewesen sind.
Also Beispiele, oder habt ihr das?
Es waren einmal, war, war da, also einmal, wie viel Geld ich im Monat verdienen sollte, circa. Das war wohl in Bezug auf irgendwelche online Aktivitäten, online Shops, wo ich dann eingekauft habe, vielleicht in einem Monat ein bisschen mehr, ja. Wo dann halt irgendwelche Faktoren drauf gelegt werden, wo ich sag, okay, so und so viel Geld hat er privat zur Verfügung. Dann halt Rankings, Scorings ganz normal, nach Wohnungen und anderen Sachen und Adressen, Telefonnummern und so weiter, wo ich dann auch wusste, okay, bestimmte Daten habe ich nur in einen weitergegeben und das Ganze wurde zusammengefasst. Ich glaube, diese ganze Zusammenfassung und Verknüpfung von persönlichen Daten, das wirkt eine ganz, ganz große Gefahr, ja.
Und haben die die, also verknüpft heißt, dass sie die dann, aber erst mal ganz kurz, wie hast du die?
Kaufen von mehreren Anbietern an. Es ist ja nicht so, dass die jetzt nur von einem Anbieter Daten bekommen, ob ich jetzt mal eine Pizza kaufe und Montag, Mararita, Donnerstag, Salami, es ist halt egal, aber es kommen halt die Daten von mehreren Töpfen, ja. Und die arbeiten halt auch mit anderen Firmen zusammen, die in anderen Bereichen oder anderen Branchen unterwegs sind. Und diese ganzen Daten, wenn die verknüpft und zusammengesammelt und dann kommen halt Anfragen von Firmen, die Marketing machen wollen, und die sagen, okay, wir möchten hier einen Datensetzer haben. Und wir haben ungefähr diese Faktoren, ja. Vielleicht von einem Durchschnittsverdienst und so weiter, Vorlieben und so weiter. Und das Ganze wird dann halt gesammelt. Und man kann mit Sicherheit, wenn man einige kleine Datensetzer hat, Rückschlüssel darauf ziehen. Und da wiederum ein weiteres Marketingmerkmal daraus bilden. Die dann abgefragt werden und dann werden die Daten halt rausgeschickt.
Du hast am Anfang gesagt, du hast diese Daten, was hast du gesagt, gefunden oder wie?
Ja, genau, ich bin zufälligerweise mal Daten eingekauft und da waren halt Daten von mir zufälligerweise mit dabei.
Das heißt, du hast vorher auch nicht gewusst, dass diese bestimmte Firma Daten von dir überhaupt hatte?
Ja, wir haben die Daten im System reingeladen und dann hab ich mal eine Kundensuche gemacht, hab mal aus Scherz meinen Namen eingegeben und dann war da Datenbewerber mit dabei.
Die Frage, die ich hatte zu sagen, du wusstest vorher aber nicht, war dir überhaupt klar, dass diese Firma überhaupt irgendwelche Daten von dir hat?
Das war eine Anfrage für eine Marketingaktion, dann gibt man halt gewisse Parameter an die Agentur, die die Adressen haben, dann sagen die, okay, wir haben so und so viele Adressen zu dem Thema, die in das Profil reinpassen, dann kriegt man halt ein paar Testdatensätze, sagt wunderbar, okay, das passt, wir nehmen den Rest auch, laden das in das System rein und machen eine Marketingkampagne.
Man könnte fast meinen, das Beispiel wäre für diese Sendung entworfen worden.
Alles klar, tschüss.
So, und jetzt gibt es ja sozusagen nicht nur die Marketingdaten, sondern es gibt auch ganz spezielle Daten und zu den ganz speziellen Daten hat Tobias eine Frage.
Hallo Tobias.
Hallo, was möchtest du wissen?
Und zwar fange ich jetzt nach der Schule eine Ausbildung als Fachinformatiker für Anwendungsentwicklung an und das in einer Firma, die EDV-gestützte Methadonautomaten herstellt. Die weisen also die Methadonautomaten automatisch an, je nachdem die Dosierung immer zu reduzieren. Und bei uns in der Firma, da gab es jetzt so die Grundüberlegung, man könnte ja eine zentrale Datenbank machen, dann müssen sich unsere Kunden nicht mehr irgendwie die Finger dreckig machen in Sachen Datensicherung, weil nebendran sitzt ein normaler Computer mit einem Windows-System. Jetzt ist unsere oder meine Überlegung natürlich, müssen wir jetzt an all die Suchtkranken ihre Daten senden. Das sind ja immerhin medizinische Daten, die sollen ja auch nur den Leuten zugänglich gemacht werden, die wirklich da was mit zu tun haben.
Richtig, da haben wir uns auch überlegt. Es gibt ja auch Pläne um die elektronische Gesundheitskarte, wo auch datenzentral gespeichert werden, die im System aber so abgelegt sind, dass nur der Arzt und der Patient oder der Krankenversicher mit seiner Karte, die wieder entschlüsseln kann. Ähm, wir wollen natürlich auch zum Beispiel, Ärzte haben genauso ihren PC, ihre Kartei mit den Krankenakten, und es wäre natürlich völlig absurd, wenn jetzt die Ärzte anfangen, diese Krankenakten den Patienten nach Hause zu schicken. Das heißt also, wir müssen auf jeden Fall für Krankenakten auch eine Sonderbehandlung haben. Und es ist natürlich auch so, dass Ärzte, also da gibt es ja auch Schweigepflicht und sowas, also da muss man glaube ich einfach so mit dem gesunden Menschen Verstand abwägen, an welchen Fällen das wirklich nicht sinnvoll ist. Was natürlich nicht heißt, dass du nicht den Arzt hast, das ist natürlich selbstverständlich ein Auskunftsrecht bei dem Arzt. Aber wenn natürlich, wenn ein Arzt...
Okay, warte mal, du würdest doch nicht wirklich ein Gesetz veranlassen und dann da irgendwo reinschreiben, wo ist der gesunde Menschenverstand geblitzt?
Nein, nein, nein.
Das heißt, es wird Ausnahmen geben.
Also es gibt auch im Datenschutzrecht gibt es auch ganz klare Gruppen in der Wirtschaft, die unter besondere Kontrolle oder besondere Maßnahmen auferlegt werden. Genau so was könnte man, also es gibt halt irgendwie Gesundheits- und Sozialdaten und genau so was könnte man auch bei diesem Datenbrief dann davon ausnehmen. Also dass Ärzte natürlich auch nicht informieren müssen und wir sagen ja auch, wir wollen wirklich nicht wirklich die kompletten Daten verschicken, sondern wir wollen im Prinzip eine abstrakte Beschreibung. Also wir haben halt irgendwie folgende Datenfelder über sie, aber wir wollen jetzt nicht unbedingt den Inhalt schicken, wobei da könnte man auch sagen, okay, dann fassen die Firmen das schon wieder so zusammen und man verliert ein bisschen Überblick. Wäre vielleicht eine Überlegung, ob man halt die Daten quasi so tut, als wenn sie geschickt werden, aber irgendwie da einfach nur Sternchen oder XXX macht, da wo die Daten wirklich stehen würden oder so was. Ich denke, da müssen wir uns irgendwie so rantasten, dass die Firmen sich einerseits nicht durchmogeln können mit Zuwagen, zu allgemeinen Beschreibungen. Also sollen schon konkret eigentlich die Daten benannt werden, um die es geht, ohne aber die tatsächlichen Daten dann mitzuteilen.
Tobias, beantwortet das deine Frage?
Ja, das beantworte meine Frage und ich bedanke mich auch. Ich bin Befürworter des Datenbriefs. Das war jetzt bloß so eine Nebenfrage.
Jo, dann alles klar.
Freut uns, dass wir die beantworten konnten.
So, ich muss nochmal doch nachfragen. Also es wird also Ausnahmen geben von Daten, die sozusagen nicht verschickt werden sollen. Und diese Ausnahmen sind aber eurer Meinung nach schon geregelt, nämlich dadurch, dass es jetzt im Datenschutzgesetz schon sozusagen eine Aufzählung gibt, was da alles sozusagen besonders schützenswert ist.
Ja, also gut, wir tun jetzt noch, als wenn es sozusagen schon beschlossene Sache ist. Das ist es natürlich nicht, aber für so ein Vorhaben, was jetzt zum Chaos Computer Club kommt, sag ich mal, sind wir jetzt schon ungewöhnlich weit in der Phase, was jetzt die Umsetzung angeht. Also wir sind absolut nicht kurz davor, dass das Gesetz jetzt morgen kommt. Aber wir sind halt weiter von dem Stand, so wir haben da jetzt mal so eine wirre Idee gehabt, sondern es gibt offensichtlich schon auch ernsthafte Bemühungen in der Politik, dieses Thema aufzunehmen und zu gucken, ob man das vielleicht umsetzen könnte. Was jetzt die konkreten Ausnahmen angeht, da gibt es jetzt auch speziell für diese Fälle eher so, dass da bestimmte Datenschutzvorschriften noch gelten. Das heißt also so, dass Firmen, die mit bestimmten Arten von Daten zu tun haben, also eben Gesundheits- und Sozialdaten, die unterliegen da besonders streng Kontrolle der Datenschutzbeauftragten. Das heißt also, es gibt schon eine Möglichkeit, diese Daten irgendwie zu benennen oder diesen Bereich von Daten, diese Art von Daten irgendwie zu benennen. Und dann könnte man auch die dann von dieser Benachrichtigungspflicht rausnehmen.
Okay, gibt es also noch ein bisschen Arbeit. So, jetzt haben wir den Paul noch am Start. Hallo Paul. Du hast auch noch eine Frage.
Ja, nämlich wir haben ja jetzt schon gesprochen vom Pizzalieferdienst bis zu den spießigsten Firmen, die wirklich Milliarden von Daten sammeln. Wer muss denn jetzt eigentlich überhaupt Daten herausgeben? Ich meine, es kann ja nicht so weit laufen, dass ich irgendwie am Ende noch Briefe schreiben muss. Ja, hör mal zu, du hast dir dann und dann irgendwie meine Profilseite angeguckt und so weiter.
Naja, du bist ja dann nicht die verantwortliche Stelle für diese Datensammlung. Also verantwortliche Stelle bezeichnet im Datenschutzrecht die Stelle, die diese Daten sammelt. Das heißt also, die Herr über die Daten ist. Wenn du jetzt da irgendwie eine Facebookseite hast, dann jemand die Daten, also dann, also gerade bei diesen sozialen Netzwerken ist es tatsächlich auch schwierig. Das haben wir ja vorhin schon gehört zu benennen, okay, welche Daten jetzt flüchtige Daten, welche Daten betreffen mich, welche Daten sind vielleicht anonym, welche lassen sich mit ein bisschen Mühe zuordnen. Ja, wobei es natürlich auch so ist, dass du dich bei deinem sozialen Netzwerk ja wahrscheinlich täglich anmeldest. Das heißt, es wäre auch überhaupt kein Problem, wenn es da einfach bei deinem, auf deiner Profilseite einen Link gibt, okay, hier und die Daten anzeigen. Noch besser wäre es eigentlich, wenn deine Profilseite einfach die versteckten Datenfelder auch sichtbar hätte. Also ist ja so, dass ein Anbieter, der hat ja noch mehr Daten gespeichert über dich, als jetzt in deinem Profil wirklich drin sind. Und das wäre für ihn ein Aufwand von vielleicht einer halben Stunde einfach diese Felder, die er ohnehin in der Datenbank hat, einfach auf deiner Profilseite mit auszugeben am Bildschirm. Das würde schon aus unserer Sicht reichen.
Also es geht nicht darum, dass es dann irgendwie ich meiner Freundin einen Brief schreiben muss, weil ich ihre Telefonnummer in meinem Handy habe, die ich auch regelmäßig benutze. Also es ein aktiver Datenbestand ist. Und es geht schon darum, dass das Leute, beziehungsweise Firmen und Behörden machen, die im großen Maßstab damit arbeiten.
Also würde sich das wirklich nur beschränken auf, was weiß ich, große Institute und...
Na ja, lass es mich so sagen.
In dem Moment, wo du das zum Beruf machst, wo du damit Geld verdienst, dann wärst du auch in der Zielgruppe für den Datenbrief.
Gewerbsmäßig heißt der richtige Begriff, der also auch, sag ich mal, nicht Gewinn absichten, aber sozusagen regelmäßig im Sinne von irgendwie... Also ein Sportverein würde ja kein Geld damit verdienen, würde aber trotzdem verpflichtet sein, das zu machen. Den Datenbrief zu schicken oder zu informieren.
Gut, dann vielen Dank und bis dahin. So, was im Chat immer noch hitzig diskutiert wird, ist dieses, was ist denn mit einem Umzug? Was ist denn, wenn ich sozusagen, ich bin gar nicht mehr da, wo ich bin und dann kommen meine Daten da nicht an, werden möglicherweise falsch zugeliefert?
Dann kommen die Briefe zurück und die Firmen haben die Pflicht, die Daten dann zu korrigieren.
Und wenn das gar nicht geht, weil sie erreichen mich ja nicht, also wissen ja gar nicht...
Dann können sie die Daten auch löschen.
Wenn ihr sowieso nicht, wo ich bin, sowieso nicht wisst, wo ich bin, dann könnt ihr auch gleich löschen, wer ich bin. Richtig?
Ja, also wenn ein Brief unzustellbar zurückkommt, dann brauche ich auch die Adresse eigentlich nicht mehr in der Datenbank.
Ja, aber jetzt ist ja doch denkbar, es gibt ja diese irgendwie mehrjährige Aufbewahrungspflicht für meine Rechnungsdaten, aber das waren die Passivdaten.
Dann kann ich sie archivieren und ausdrucken, abheften.
Mir scheint, ihr habt eine Weile drüber nachgedacht.
Ja, also es ist klar, wir haben uns wirklich in die...
Beim Rot-Rotweil.
Nein, das war nicht einfach, oder wir sind ja mitten in der Diskussion, also die Sache ist ja in Bewegung, das ist keine Sache, wo wir jetzt sagen so, jetzt wir haben hier irgendwie die Weisheit mit Löffeln gefressen, sondern es ist wichtig noch, dass wirklich der Input auch kommt und auch, wir versuchen natürlich auch mit den Firmen zu sprechen. Also eine ganz interessante Information war einfach mal im großen Raum mit IT-Beauftragten, IT-Vorantwortlichen von großen Firmen, großen Versicherungen, Verlagshäusern, weiß nicht was. Und die haben gesagt, okay, der Datenbrief kostet uns drei Euro. So ist nämlich nicht nur die 55 Cent, die da anfallen an Porto, sondern ich muss ja die ganzen verwaltungsmäßigen Vorgänge da drin, also ich muss möglicherweise ein Zusatzmodul für meine Unternehmenssoftware programmieren. Ich muss das auch alles datenschutzrechtlich abklären. Ich muss dann einen Anwalt beauftragen, einen Juristen beauftragen, der diesen Datenbrief formuliert, also der die Formulierung alle genau gesetzeskonform macht. Ich muss einen Grafiker ansetzen, der diesen Datenbrief irgendwie gestaltet. Ich muss den Serienbrief, das heißt ich muss Druckerei und so ist es so. Es bleibt also auch nicht bei diesen 55 Cent an Porto. Es entstehen schon Kosten, aber das sind ja Sachen auch, die kommen dann auch über die Jahre, das heißt also die würden dann, klar so was amortisiert sich dann auch. Und wir sagen es würde halt auch in den Firmen sinnvolle Prozesse einsetzen, mal drüber nachzudenken, ob man diese Daten wirklich zu lange braucht. Und insofern, was ja dann auch wieder die Speicherkosten verringert, die Offenbarungskosten, insofern würden die Kosten dann auch wieder relativ zu sehen sein.
Okay, es taucht gerade zeitgleich am Telefon und im Chat die Frage nach dem Sitz der Firmen auf.
Hallo Peter. Hallo. Was ist genau deine Frage?
Na ja, also in Deutschland kann ich ja nur dann den Datenbrief, also das ist jetzt eine Frage eher, verlangen von Firmen, die auch in Deutschland ihren Sitz haben. Wenn ich das... ist es dann nicht eine Möglichkeit, einfach der Firmen zu sagen, okay, ich habe meinen Sitz halt, was weiß ich, in Spanien, in den USA oder sonst irgendwo und den ganzen dann so ausweichen.
Das Facebook-Problem. Ja gut, durchsetzen kann man sowas natürlich nur, wenn die Firmen tatsächlich auch in Deutschland rechtlich greifbar sind. Das hat sich ja auch bei Facebook schon als ein praktisches Problem rumgesprochen, zwar nicht zu unserer Verbraucherschutzministerin, aber doch immerhin. Dass also Facebook, dass sie zwar sagen, ja wir sind hier in Deutschland, aber natürlich, wenn es denn hart auf hart kommt, gehe ich persönlich davon aus, dass sie sich auch ganz schnell wieder aus dem Staub machen werden und dann eben nicht mehr greifbar sind. Letztendlich betrifft es alle Firmen, die zumindest in der EU, also da sind wir gut, da kommen wir schon auf die nächste Ebene. Wir reden jetzt erstmal über Deutschland. Wir müssen ja noch prüfen, ob das Ganze mit der EU vertretbar wäre, mit dem Binnenmarkt sicher, das muss man auch prüfen. Klar, es geht erstmal für Firmen, die ihren Sitz oder ihren Geschäftsmittelpunkt hier in Deutschland haben. Es geht denn für Firmen, die vielleicht hier Geschäfte machen wollen auch.
Ja klar, nur die Frage ist, können die sich denn im Grunde nicht entziehen, indem sie dann einfach das behaupten, dass sie eben die Daten halt, die sind dann halt in USA, auf dem Server oder sonst irgendwo. Es wäre eine Möglichkeit sozusagen, sich dem zu entziehen.
Nee, es geht dann nicht darum, wo die Daten sind, sondern wo die Firma ist.
Da hat es ja keinen Zugriff darauf, wenn die Firma in USA die Daten hat, dann kannst du mit dem deutschen Gesetz, haben die ja gar nicht mehr ran.
Also es hat sich am Ende gezeigt, dass je größer so eine Firma wird, desto eher hat sie keinen Bock, sich jeweils mit den lokalen Regierungen, da wo viele Leute herkommen, da anzulegen. Und meistens gehen die dann dann auch schon auf die lokale Gesetzgebung mit zu.
Also ihr meint dann nicht, dass es dann sozusagen so eine Art Datenlagerungstourismus kommt?
Man kann es am besten bei Google sehen, die ja jetzt mit Street View, da gibt es natürlich noch viel Kritik und hin und her, aber trotzdem haben die ja dieses Street View Software oder das Portal für Deutschland ziemlich krass angepasst, was sie in einem anderen Stadtteil nicht gemacht haben. Obwohl sie natürlich auch sagen können, ach naja, gut, wir sitzen ja eigentlich in Amiland. Es ist natürlich ein Problem, natürlich wird es wahrscheinlich, könnte ich mir vorstellen, die eine oder andere Firma gehen, die sagt, ja, vielen Dank, dass du bei uns in Timbuktu bestellt hast, wir schicken dir auch gleich mal 40.000 Spam Mails und auch das Produkt, das du bestellt hast. Aber im Großen und Ganzen, die Frage ist umgedreht, würdest du sagen, wir brauchen den Datenbrief gar nicht, weil es könnte ja sowieso sein, dass die Firmen sich ins Ausland absetzen?
Ich komm nur deswegen drauf, ich hab die Erfahrung gemacht, große Firmen haben inzwischen, lagern zum Beispiel ihre Buchhaltung, was weiß ich, in Indien aus.
Aber müssen die Buchhaltung ja trotzdem noch nach deutschem Recht durchführen, das ist ja der Punkt. Ja, sie wird in Indien gemacht, aber sie muss nach den Kriterien des deutschen Rechts gemacht werden.
Darf sie übrigens nicht ohne weiteres.
Auch das noch.
Also darf sie Daten nicht ohne weiteres aus der EU rausbringen, wenn derjenige nicht zugestimmt hat. Das wäre dann noch so ein Detailproblem. Aber wie gesagt, der Lageort der Daten ist nicht entscheidend. Entscheidend ist, wo die Firma denn ihren Geschäftsmittelpunkt hat oder wo sie ihr Geschäft abwickelt. Und in dem Moment, wo die Firma hier aus Deutschland oder nach Deutschland Pakete verschickt, wird sie das schon wegen des Portos von hier aus machen.
Ja, wenn es noch Pakete sind, aber wenn es nicht der Software ist, gibt es ja keine Pakete mehr und sowas.
Ja, das ist richtig. Aber im Netz ist es so, da denke ich, das ist jetzt die nächste spannende Diskussion, wenn es jetzt darum geht, wie das Internet reglementiert wird. Da denke ich, da müssen wir einfach damit leben, dass es nach einem Herkunftsprinzip geht. Das heißt also bei Firmen, die wirklich im Netz sind und auch nur da agieren, dann müssen wir halt damit leben, dass die Firmen erst mal da, die Gesetzgebung, oder dass die Gesetzgebung für Firmen geht, in dem Land, wo sie sind. Das ist eine Sache, da müssen wir wahrscheinlich im Netz einfach mit leben. Aber das ist ein anderes Thema.
Da gibt es auch eine Rechtsprechung, eine kleine Tendenz, die hingeht, wenn sich eine Firma konkret an eine Zielgruppe wendet, dann ist sie auch nach diesem Recht tatsprach zu machen. Es gab zum Beispiel ein Gericht von ein deutsches Gericht, das die New York Times zu irgendwas verurteilt hat. Das ist natürlich die Frage, ob das durchsetzbar ist, aber sowas soll es mittlerweile auch schon geben.
Peter, ist deine Frage erklärt?
Alles klar. Jetzt haben wir noch ein paar Minuten.
Wir müssen noch ganz dringend auf eine Veranstaltung hinsetzen.
Bevor ihr hier schamlos Werbung machen dürft. Das geht ja gar nicht im öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk. Ich wollte fragen, ihr habt jetzt die ganze Zeit immer schon gesagt, das ist so eine Diskussion oder wird auch ernsthaft darüber geredet.
Und überhaupt mal ganz konkret www.ccc.de slash Datenbrief.
Das wollte ich ja meinen, oder?
Nee, mit wem wir uns darüber unterhalten haben. Setzen 6. Also es gab zuletzt Gespräche auch mit dem Innenminister, mit Herrn de Maizière. Und die Signale dort sind eigentlich sehr positiv, die wir dort aus den Gesprächen...
Gerade im Hinsicht dessen, dass der de Maizière auch jemand ist, der gesagt hat, ach ja, wisst ihr eigentlich, das ist mit dem Sperren doch eine ganz coole Idee. Für wie glaubhaft haltet ihr das, dass da wirklich was bei rumkommt?
Das ähm...
Nein, ich denke, das sind einfach zwei Gescheite. Keine Themen. Das eine ist, wie wir mal mit dem Netz umgehen. Das ist das, was ich gerade eben schon angedeutet hab, dass es einfach da, denke ich mal, auch deutlich unterschiedliche Ansichten gibt, wie wir jetzt den Bürger vor den üblen Sachen im Netz, in Anführungszeichen, beschützen. Da haben wir einfach einen anderen Ansatz als jetzt den Innenminister von der CDU. Das andere ist natürlich der Datenschutz. Und das sind auch Sachen, die sich jetzt überhaupt gar nicht widersprechen.
Das ist schon klar. Was der Herr Demisier jetzt gesagt hat, ist ein bisschen widersprüchlich zu dem, was die ganze Zeit vorher gesagt wurde. Von der ganzen Regierung auch. Da war ja Sperren zwischendurch auch mal vom Tisch. Die Frage ist also nicht so sehr, haben diese beiden Themen mit einer Hälfte zu tun. Die Frage ist, wie glaubwürdig ist das Interesse von einem Herrn Demisier?
Es kommt natürlich schon, er hat das Thema aufgebracht, aber letztendlich haben wir nicht nur mit ihm da gesessen, sondern es gab einen runden Tisch, einfach mit Wirtschaftsvertretern. Also wir haben schon den Eindruck, dass das Thema da ernsthaft diskutiert wird. Also es ist halt nicht so eine Spinnerei vom CCC, sondern das Thema wird da wahrgenommen.
Der Datenbrief ereilt uns also möglicherweise, und ob das eine gute Sache ist oder nicht, haben wir heute diskutiert, zusammen mit Herrn Erdgeist und Frank Rosengardt vom CCC, die jetzt noch eine Minute Zeit haben, um schamlos Werbung für eine Veranstaltung zu machen.
Nein, ich wollte mal ganz kurz sagen, dass unsere Punkte zum Datenbrief, dass wir die auf www.ccc.de slash datenbrief aufgeschrieben haben. Da werden wir jetzt auch so ein paar Sachen, die wir in den letzten paar Wochen gelernt haben, noch einarbeiten. Das ist aber erstmal so die erste Anlaufstelle zu dem Thema. Das ist auch eine Kontaktadresse, nämlich datenbrief.de, wenn ihr uns schreiben wollt. Werbung machen wollte ich noch für unsere eigene Veranstaltung, die SIGINT. Gerade wenn ihr aus dem Westen von Deutschland seid oder mal Lust habt, wieder nach Köln zu fahren, das ist auch eine schöne Stadt, dann findet vom 22. bis zum 24. Mai diese Veranstaltung statt. Das ist ein, ich möchte nicht sagen ein Mini-Kongress, aber es ist eine Veranstaltung, wo es auch viel um unsere Themen geht, um Datenschutz, Saatensicherheit, Netzte. Die SIGINT, also ein Kongress.
Ist das in einem Turnhallengebäude oder wo findet das statt?
Es ist im Media Park in Köln. Das ist ein Gebäude, ein Areal, wo sich Firmen aus dem Medienumfeld angesiedelt haben. Da gibt es einen Veranstaltungsbereich. Und da gibt es so Vorträge, Workshops.
Was zu den Themen und Motto dieses Jahr ist?
Die SIGINT hat keine Motivation.
Motivation?
SIGINTCCCDE, also SIGINTCCCDE.
Wann kommt die nächste Datenschleuer?
Ich zinner mache, zwei Wochen.
Alles klar, wir werden sehen. Euch vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und Mitmachen. Ihr könnt den Podcast auf fritz.de in zwei Stunden hören und auf chaosradio.de bestimmt ab morgen. Ich wünsche euch viel Spaß, übergebe euch in die Hände von Smith & Smart, die euch jetzt mit Mashup-Musik bewerfen werden. Durchaus hörenswert und sehr zu empfehlen. Und verabschiede mich mit dem, mit dem ich mich immer verabschiede. Wenn es klappt. Kann mal irgendjemand was total unverfänglich erzählen, während ich mich hier nicht weiterblamine? Es wird Zeit, dass ich mich hier vom Acker mache.